I'm live!
Hello everybody!
I have two people here with me today for the Nessie Cup
tournament!
Would you guys like to introduce yourselves?
This is gonna be my forever team for today.
Oh wait, sorry, they can't hear you my description!
Okay, good, good, good, good!
it's okay i'll put you in your picture you can go now now
i'm scared oh wait sorry i think i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm hi i'm him or himalayas but
call me him happy to be here hey senox you're next hi my
name is senox uh you play competitive apex i don't know
that's about it he's the guys he's the guy that looks like
gibraltar irl Those who are wondering, we've talked about
him before.
So...
Wait, what team are we?
Team 6?
Yeah, we're Team 6.
Wait, we Hyrule.
We got Countdown.
We got Countdown?
Not so.
Wait, that's pretty good.
Pretty good.
We were, like, discussing Strats earlier.
So, is the, is the, is the, is like, the challenge is public
yet?
Or is it, like, still, like, only on stream?
type deal.
I had the thing open on my stream.
Oh, okay.
I'm just going to put it on my.
Oh my God, I can put images on my stream now.
I wasn't able to in the past.
But yeah, we were discussing our challenges, what we're
doing and stuff.
So have we decided who's going to be doing what yet?
Um, can we put them again?
No, I mean, for the most part, I think the only individual
ones that matter is the FOV and no attachments.
Yeah.
can do whatever you just pick up like a sniper you just do
whatever so like we we delegated heme to be the 90 fov
because she's not streaming so so so chat she doesn't have a
chat to go through 90 fov and other than that we try to
decide who's going to do the no attachments and the p20 gun
any volunteers who's playing wraith who's going to get the
kidnap off i think senox is doing the the RAFE thing right
oh beautiful yeah oh my gosh also wait there's a comp
challenge in here too yeah it's not gonna be Fortik yeah but
it's just one point because it's like either you do the
raise or you do you get you get like one point off of the
the comp uh how much what what are they there's only one
wraith one also right yeah there's only one race so it's
either one or the I feel like I think Sunrise is right Just
do like our own comp because like For the ammo and the
shield cells And all that Definitely enough Yeah Hold on I'm
being cringe I'm getting a loop path That's not good I think
it's PY's changing every game right I don't think so well
it's different I think maybe world's edge we get like
Countdown the entire time and then Storm Point We get like a
different Obviously, different POI.
I mean, we could always ask tempo.
Also, chat, how's the volume for everybody?
I hate audio balancing.
Oh, guys, this is not bingo.
It's basically whoever does the most challenges per game.
Or win the game gets, like, money.
Gets, like, 1,500 per team.
So it's not bingo.
It's just whoever does the most challenges.
Oh, he needs a little...
low.
Okay let me boost up he needs volume.
Boop.
He's great.
Like you can get up your mic for us.
Wait I think it's good.
Does I don't know?
Okay yeah yeah.
Wait I think you're good.
I think you're good.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Oh we're not count down.
We're not.
We're tree.
We're not tree?
The map said team six countdown.
But we're team six.
Wait who has countdown?
Wait team 2s countdown wait what wait dupe is a bastard guy
stole her poi i mean she's fine how the fuck did numbers
don't matter oh my gosh i mean true tree is tree is really
easy um i know i like it i like g honestly okay it's good
for the game are we doing rampart loba raids still yes i
think so okay we could we could drop rampart for damage i
was just gonna we were just doing for knock damage we could
just drop rampart for like watson or something because meds
might be a problem i mean i could do it it's perfect
whoever's playing that character uh i can do i can do any of
them watson caustic or rampart so it really depends on which
is the best one um i mean caustic's like hard meta right now
i'm calm but i don't know how competitive this is gonna be i
think if i mean It's going to be sweaty.
I feel like, I mean, not going to lie, but some teams are
very imbalanced.
Yeah, some of the teams are really imbalanced.
I played like, I streamed Apex once last week, so.
So these teams are pretty unbalanced.
We're playing the game on easy mode.
We're sitting center zone.
Mimi, I nominate you to do no attachments.
Okay.
I might be Tony.
You're supposed to fight back.
You're not just supposed to accept it.
I don't know, Doki.
That sounds bush.
I don't think you are.
I can't believe you would do this.
I've just met you, but you should do the known attachments.
Since you think you know everything.
Are you the IGL?
Senox, who should do it?
And you know what?
No, Senox, you pick.
You're the IGL.
Realistically, who's worse?
If we want to be real.
what's your if you want if you want me to choose that's what
i'm saying what's your unfortunately who is worse oh i am
not the idealist definitely one of y'all yes i just telling
us who is the worst player out of the two of us he mean
what's your rank oh i'm that i'm like diamondish i don't
know higher ranked than me oh whoa not right now oh my gosh
currently today oh my gosh today what's your rank today nor
i'm like what's that my gold oh thank god i'm flat right now
okay you can do i would no shot i'm flat right now so you're
goaded so i the lowest ranked the lowest ranked members
should play the no attachments in p20 yeah there we go there
we go we figured it out what's your rank senox yeah what's
your rank senox i don't know i was i got massive when the
season came out or i got pregnant when the season came out
and i haven't pulled it since oh so you are a master so he's
master's yeah so he's still the highest rank highest rank
igl it's the rule it i sent you the thing it's it's pretty
easy it's shriek whoever's on beacon character you just loot
mid and hit beacon someone else looks like i'm someone else
okay the other side it doesn't my thing watson rampart or
caustic igl it's up to me whichever one you want to play i
don't think it matters i mean rampart we could use it to get
more and more sniper knocks and like overall damage um
caustic would just be better for actually winning games yeah
but like we're not here to win games we're here to do
challenges um is does watson do anything for any of these an
arc star stick you could turn all your nades into arc stars
um
all right okay so i guess it's all rng on how many meds we
get honestly okay i'll just pick up rampart then if there's
or i'll just pick up rampart then just for the damage
padding if we're doing i mean it'll be good for snipers if
we're doing damage padding yeah yeah use your alt three
times what how do i oh wait loba that'll be fast for loba
love you yeah i feel like we should do the evo harvester
like instantly just travel travel to all the we can just hit
them on the we can hit them on the way yeah okay i guess it
all just depends where the zone is because if it's across
the map we could just play like you know what i mean we have
to use our evac towers our three evac towers yeah oh and we
have a loba to get those eva towers oh my god three evacs at
the same time we're thinking we were supposed to start our
game like nine minutes ago who is not
girl's not here girl the host isn't here in the lobby i
mean in my mic actually i think we play watson oh never mind
if a lot of the people are playing gibby kossick for the the
challenge we're like actually gonna get took by gibby
kossick out without watson jim yeah that is that is so smart
i nominate doki to play watson oh my god that's good because
i was gonna nominate myself anyway thank you yeah i can do
watson i used to play her she's so cute i love her where is
girl girl where are you you're the host all right i muted my
mic i'm so anxious
they're so serious
bro they're like they're like metacrafting earlier before i
started the stream i was just like hey
the anxiety you know i found out that wasn't a thought okay
by participating we each get like 500 i thought we get 1 500
i was like fuck yeah i don't care how well we do we get a
thousand five hundred dollars each and then i realized i
can't read and it actually says every team gets a thousand
five hundred so i get five hundred dollars i get 500 for
participating and just being there which is great because
that means Because there's three tournaments.
So that means if I signed up for all three, technically I
can get 1,500.
It's still better than nothing.
Exactly.
It's still better than being a professional player.
Sorry, that's a bit.
That's a low blow.
It's still better.
I still earn more than a regular professional player.
professional player so So that's all that matters.
That's all that matters.
Oh my god.
Anyway, yeah, people are very I was like when I okay I
remember I saw the teams and I was like, oh shit, this is
like some of these teams are very very like Like really good
and then I was like maybe the mini games are like actual
mini games, you know, like no punch Or like like no weapons
punch out stuff like that and I was like wait you actually
have to play the game And I was just like I was like what do
you mean what why do some teams have two friends I'm not
afraid of guys guys I'm washed I mean like two current
friends sorry let me be more specific two current friends I
was like what the fuck
Apex was last week!
Oh, let me know.
Thank you for the 50 gift of ships.
Thank you.
Alright, anyway.
So, I'm just like, folk, they were like, let's try and win.
I was like, win.
Skyhooker Shadows, because of a winning tree.
Yay!
We're starting!
Alright, I got this.
I got Watson picked out.
Wait, where is she?
we
all just get a bunch of shield cells together we can make a
heart instantly how big does that heart need to be i don't
think it has to be that big i think just needs to be a heart
i think just arguably a heart i think just one person can
just make the heart and then we're good to go i've never
made a ship that cell heart have you oh i can do it i can
good ship and beacon wait Wait, we got beacon?
Fuck yeah.
Wait, I land in the middle, right?
Yeah.
I can land on the front side.
All right.
Yep.
We're going to be doing the no loot challenge.
We just got to get the zone and lobo loot.
All right.
What's the no loot challenge?
We just don't get loot because we're landing tree.
That's fine.
We have lobo.
We can just pick the loot up.
Literally, I just pulled up the gold.
Oh, like the actual challenge.
And I was like, wait, what?
All right.
I don't remember how the loot.
Pat was, but I know I was in mid.
You just loot all the mid and then you can hit beacon
whenever.
Yay, okay.
Actually, you can land on the beacon and hit a... Can you
still hit double hit beacons?
I forgot about that.
Oh my god.
Okay, hang on.
FOV.
Oh yeah, FOV 90.
No attachments.
Remember, zero attachments.
Okay.
Ooh, I gotta run double heavy.
It's actually not that bad.
No, it's just bad on stream.
It just looks terrible.
Oh.
no p20s on my side there is a zone out yet i have a blue bag
give me nades all right oh i have a blue bag too oh my god i
literally feel like i'm in a if you're doing sniper here is
i'm gonna scan
we can go we should wait we should go we should go skull
piercer i'll let this build on end up all right i only found
two stacks of shield cells that's really i didn't get to be
honest Do we get any EVACs?
We have one EVAC.
Let's try to hit this balloon and pray we don't die hitting
it.
I feel like, yeah, we shouldn't use any of our EVACs yet.
We won't have to just use one to get in the zone.
No, our EVACs.
I have my ult.
Should I drop it?
No, no, no, no.
I don't know.
I mean, just drop it now because you recharge it fast.
We just need to use it three times, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, just drop it now.
Do it.
Okay.
I'll go.
Yeah, and we'll just look at it for, like, one second.
I'm gonna loot and I'm gonna grab a shield cell oh beautiful
how badly I want this I don't get the asterisks too I have
two four I five I have five needs already I'm gonna see you
guys uh fly my almost my whole bottom row is needs oh wait
we cannot we can combine there's needs land on uh this roof
actually I can't wait isn't there people there oh they're on
me go back over here go back Run back over here, run over
here.
I'm gonna kill, just go.
Well, oh, I might be dead.
We can craft if we die.
Alright, we're fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Come inside, run, run, run, run deep to the tunnel.
Alright.
They're aping us, hard aping us.
Whoa!
This guy's on Revenant.
There you go.
Keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
Left or right?
Oh, right, okay.
You might have to hold them here.
Oh, they're literally here.
They're here.
Oh, yeah, I'm dead.
I didn't, I didn't know it was left or right.
I cracked off.
you're pushing hard pushing hard eating hard eating i'm not
gonna lie just run run run did not hear them climb up there
if you're gonna die if you're gonna die at least kill
yourself with names oh wait yeah i'm actually gonna kill
myself with names if you're gonna die okay i mean we
technically did accomplish some of these challenges we just
bro this relative character is op did you i needed myself i
needed myself yeah we got that that's all you needed
amazing it's okay we got like okay I don't think we won this
game so okay I had 90 FOV and I had I didn't get a knock
with the P20 I just had the P20 for no reason but I had no
attachments hey that's two challenges right two points for
me yeah yeah that's two points I should have like just ran
to the right should have walked back to you I was confused
too I didn't know if we were going left or right I was just
like I'm like I heard the revenant alt and the jump and we
were just dead.
No, we split up.
One of us could have lived.
I just didn't know which way to go.
It's okay.
We got three challenges, even though I don't think those
three challenges...
We were not last.
We got 19th place.
Why did somebody die before us?
Yeah, I don't know.
I guess fucking losers.
And then they die before us.
Imagine dying first.
I know, right?
No, I mean.
We didn't die first.
Imagine dying first.
Wait, was there no...
What do you mean, guys?
That was totally sound.
Okay, let me just harass Tempo into...
Into posting game 2.
Putting in the game 2 list.
Oh yeah, after the game ends, have one player...
I mean, we could technically post our stuff now.
yeah we could please be accurate we will be going over the
VODs thanks oh they can't go after my VODs I have no replay
um I don't have permissions yet so maybe they open it up at
the end of the game oh I mean that makes sense for a tempo
you can't look at my VOD he has to wait until my streams
that over yeah turn down senox
actually was just i just i just coin flipped the game on
them right setting but they didn't have a beacon character
i'm just glad that i don't have to play 90 fov well what if
they have 90 fov again in the in the card doubt it they
might though they might it's okay i really do feel like I
don't know, they might get harder or they might like change
the guns that you have to get knocks with.
I'm pretty sure they'll change like comps and stuff too.
Yeah, I think the comp one will change every game and then
the guns will change.
Uh-huh.
I'm pretty sure.
It's okay, this was just warm up.
This was warm up here.
And sort of, we sort of landed on them to be fair.
Oh yeah, I know.
I was actually just assuming they'd be gone because they're
landing next to Enzone but they just weren't playing a
beacon character.
that was that was pretty that was pretty unlucky it's okay
if this team wins then we technically we won one again yeah
technically we won the game because we got killed by the the
winners so we would have liver guide lists i'm
gonna message tempo be like let me see game two let me see
the game two list so we can metacraft
and see
tempo show me game two
not that
oh doki i think i have some people from your community
following me on twitter oh oh that's nice wait tempo's
making the card in between games he's done he doesn't even
No, it's in game two!
Okay, we should give him ideas.
We should give him ideas.
He literally was like, I don't even know.
I'm literally making the card right now.
One of the challenges could be have a fat ass.
So, check.
I got y'all covered.
Which that means just play Loba.
Just play Loba.
Okay, chat, we can influence tempo.
He'll do what I'll say.
Like, in Beases.
i mean honestly some fuse action could be funny oh okay okay
one of the cards should be one of the challenges should be
play fuse oh knockout whip punch yes yes we're yeah yeah
yeah yeah um i've got 10 million things open and going out
bro temple has seven monitors holy wait can i show this on
stream man is not oh my god oh wait this team's dying oh
they're kind of living though this revenue is cooking like
who is this who is this that's dropped oh my god tempo has
fucking seven months he has a laptop Do a finisher on them,
Rev.
On the side.
Look, the drop is a serious person.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah, that's thinking it's safe.
Oh my god.
He has a second computer monitor on the side.
Like a second computer.
I'm sorry, Temple, if you're watching this and you didn't
want me to leak that.
Oh, he can let me, he said I can show it.
Guys, look at his fucking setup.
It's actually crazy.
Oh, my God.
That's like, that's like sensor overload for me.
Jesus Christ.
Look at this, guys.
Oh, it's...
Oh.
Look at this.
Seven fucking monitors.
XQC was right.
How do you...
That is like, like, three monitors is already too much for
me.
Seven mon- two mouse, two keyboards.
Actually, three mouse, four keyboards, seven monitors, one
PC, a camera, a mic.
My God.
He had to, like, check.
to make sure there was nothing confidential.
My god, he needs to go further beyond.
Five cats.
Six consoles.
Oh my god.
This is this is like he organized this tournament, by the
way, guys.
Like, you need to have at least seven monitors to be able to
organize this tournament.
That's actually crazy.
That's a lot of PC.
Zero wall.
It's okay, guys.
I can, like, peer pressure him to buy Doki merch.
And then he can put...
He's thinking with a super chat.
Thank you, Jake.
By the way, I muted myself.
I feel like I don't want to, like, bother with the shit I
say.
i can peer pressure him to buy doki merch and put that way
let me message that if if i send okay if you you should buy
my merch to decorate your wall
it's so it's so empty
True.
And then it's like, it's like free.
Okay, it's not free advertising because like he has to pay
for my merch.
But it's like, it's, oh, it is free advertising for me.
Because he's the one that spent money.
So it's technically free advertising for me.
Okay, I should like let you guys actually watch the game.
Not look at, not look at Tempo's fucking setup.
modders in zero doking merch.
It's a free win-win.
Exactly.
So anytime, anytime someone comes in, he's like TSM's
manager.
So like, I might be able to get TSM fans to buy my merch.
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but I'm playing
the game.
This is me right now.
No, don't die.
You have to win.
So it technically means we died to the champion.
You guys can't die.
You guys, as in me, I can't die.
God, I'm so good at this game.
Holy shit.
Seven kills already.
Number one revved me.
You can call me number one pred.
No!
Drop!
I mean, Doki!
Don't die!
I have to live!
No!
I died!
It's okay.
It's just...
That was...
Guys, just so you guys know, that was not me.
I would never play like that.
Play it.
It's okay.
This is actually me.
It was a little spectator bug that happened.
So I am...
Wait, who is on my team?
who is on my team okay that is i'm dz i'm i dz zero it's
like dokey dokey's bird zero dokey's zero bird wait what is
he is he playing right now is he on bengalore no he's on is
he on bengalore okay am i on bengalore i'm on bengalore
Doki's zero bird.
There we go.
I always knew.
I know!
The thing is, Doki is universal.
I can be from any country.
So, like, today I'm in Australia.
Today I'm on Australia.
It'll be funny if we actually did influence Tempo's Game 2
bingo.
Or not bingo.
What is it called?
Like, challenge sheet.
This feels like you've made this.
I made this.
You're you're zero.
I'm zero
Australian dokey.
I mean I'm technically like I'm like halfway there
Australians swear a lot.
I swear a lot.
They say I don't say that
That is sadly not in my is it sad?
Sadly, that is not in my natural vocabulary.
You hesitated.
Oh, what was I gonna say?
You'll never know.
You'll never... They say what?
I don't know.
What would they be saying?
Do we keep our POI?
Oh, no, it changes.
Wait, it changes?
Oh, I mean, I'm...
I don't want... I didn't like tree anyway.
I didn't like tree anyway.
Drop the bomb, mate.
You can't say I have the pass!
I'm only half Australian!
You can say can't.
Yeah.
I can't say that way.
What?
I can't do that!
What do you mean?
I can't understand what you're talking about.
Oh my god.
Yeah, half a pass.
Half the word.
Oh my god, who's gonna win?
I like how nobody's doing me.
The Valk- the Valk- we should have done the Valkyrie thing.
We could have got one more.
Whoa!
I died.
Doki Zero Bird!
How could you?
You're supposed to be the champion!
How could you do this?
All right, who's in this team?
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
Who's- okay.
Wait, wait a minute.
Is that Sykes?
Okay, they're on the same team.
is technically the same thing.
It's now Doki's Sykes Bird.
They're on the same team.
It's the same thing.
I'm on the same team.
13 kills.
Because he's a pro player.
He's a controller player.
The only thing we were missing was a controller player.
Okay.
do we're all in m and wait a sunox controller or mmk let me
look at the input real fast i just don't remember okay
they're also m and k look i'm sorry we were nerfed so hard
okay we we were we were nerfed so hard we're all full m and
k players what were we supposed to do what were we supposed
to do
We were all M&K.
Movement can't save us.
Oh, why is that?
Oh, that's like the Pathfinder thingy, right?
Oh my god, where are they?
That poor Gibraltar is just floating in this...
That poor Cossack that was in the middle of nowhere.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I'm the content creator!
What do you mean?
has three people.
An Apex streamer, a pro player, and the content creator.
I am the content creator.
You cannot put all the expectations on me.
We should be putting all the expectations on the pro player.
If we are blaming anybody, it's definitely not me.
Look, I am the content creator I want to tempo finish this
fucking bingo card No, I'm gonna blame you I'm not two
things No, no, no, no, no I put myself in the content
creator role I put myself in the content creator There's no
coping here Alright, let's see did he finish the list i
don't think he did i'd be so surprised how many challenges
did we complete uh i mean i'm pretty sure it has was it just
three well i don't think we got a lot we died instantly we
died instantly i had so many things though no we really
didn't though we didn't have chance um i had f of e then no
attachments and then the nade right that's it was it really
that What was the name?
Okay, yeah, it's a three.
Total.
Okay, three.
It's okay.
Other people did three as well.
Or not last in the challenges either.
Who the fuck did A?
That's insane.
Oh my god.
Zero got zero.
Damn.
Wait, they got zero.
At least we didn't get zero.
We're not zero.
They might be the team that died last, too.
Or died first.
If they got zero, that's That is actually unfortunate.
Guys, I just need you guys to know, chat.
Three is the average.
There's like six other people with three.
We're not alone.
Guys, we got the average.
We got it.
I have to, like, really think about them.
And honestly, like...
If we would have maybe played slow, where we maybe would
have had more time, finish some of these like little easy
ones i don't know yeah we could have got their little heart
our little heart and then we could yeah like even before we
left the poi like we could have did the fucking we could
just not we could just not play hard zone then because if
we're playing hard so we have to go center zone but if we
die early we just get zero done let's just yeah let's just
do all the easy stuff in our in our poi and then move on i'm
done
Yeah, I hope he actually changes the challenges.
Oh, no, he is.
He's like doing them in between games.
All right, we just do all the ones we can do instantly
without having to do any work, and then we just get the
other ones out.
And we just, if we do get in the game, do the other ones?
I'm done.
Yeah, yeah, just get the easy ones out.
All right, we just have like some of the challenges done
then zero, like that poor man over there.
Chat, do not worry.
I will not call out the person that got zero.
you might be able to find out on girl's stream yourself
if you really want to know you won't find out on my stream I
am muted I hate I am muted thank you for the 50 gifted chips
bacon thank you thank you what I'm not gonna call anybody
else wait so is it whoever completes the most challenges
over all six games or is it just whoever completes it for
that game for that game okay but the one the team that
completes the most challenges overall goes to the finals you
get the money to go to the finals two teams two teams that
completes the most challenges overall uh gets to uh go to
the finals uh but like you get to win a thousand five
hundred for the most challenges completed per game 500 for
winning first place or a thousand 500 for completing the
most challenges okay i'm looking at right now six teams make
finals off of challenges one per game and then two
individual players with most kills
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's either but so like finals is
just dependent on challenges oh yeah we actually just need
to spam challenges with one game and just get infinite we
just do the bare minimum ones we can do and then if we have
a good game we crank out like 10.
yeah exactly do we do the same comp or do we should we play
the comp guy no i want to see what the challenges are i want
to see what he changes because if we're not playing if we're
not if we're not rotating then we shouldn't put that comp
what finals okay here i'll tell you guys uh that has a
challenge for playing the actual comp because it's just a
free challenge basically yeah basically um it is basically
like whichever There's four tournaments, but I can't count.
So there's three tournaments that are like the qualifying
tournaments.
I should sign up for next week too.
I didn't sign up for next week, but if I'd be like, Temple,
can I join next week?
Maybe he'll be like, okay.
Anyway, anyway.
At least sign up for like two.
But you can sign up for three.
Anyway, so there's three tournaments.
And they're each like invitational.
And so basically...
the team that wins the most challenges in each tournament
goes towards the finals.
And the finals, so like, the finals would be composed of all
the teams that are, like, the best of each individual
tournament.
Each individual tournament is different.
The second one, the reason why I didn't sign up for the
second one was because the second one was actually more
reliant on, like, FPS skills.
But I didn't realize this tournament, I thought the
mini-games, when they mean mini-games, it's, like,
hide-and-seek and stuff like that.
you're not actually like playing everyone's asking for the
challenge trying hard and stuff like that but now i realize
oh this is actually low-key try hard so i might as well sign
up for the second one as well maybe ahead of time sorry i
had to listen to what they're saying anyway i didn't realize
okay so now now i'm like oh i might as well sign up for the
second one because the first one is basically like the
second one and i already got that out of the way So I might
as well sign up for the second one also Because the second
one is also like Like shooting your gun So
I thought You know I thought they'd be like punching boxing
Stuff like that Because it says mini games But I didn't
realize What they meant was a bingo chart
Anyway Anyway as I was saying um so it's basically whichever
team completes the most challenges and also whichever two
individuals do the most kills they get straight to the
finals and then the finals is composed of all the teams that
did really well in the invitation is and then boom a
thousand five easy 500 dollars that i make it to the finals
yeah there is a lot of um really two teams got 10 challenges
completed and they tied for first oh my gosh by the way like
it's actually oh yeah i'm gonna say who placed like it's
actually crazy though i'd be surprised if like i get into
the second the other two tournaments because apparently a
lot of people signed up for these like a lot of people
obviously i can't give up the numbers but like um they when
i they're like I had they're like they're like I have to
check blank amount of Pete applicants I was like holy fuck
and I just sent I sent like a dokey amber doge emoji of him
sleeping I was like good luck
a lot it was a lot of people I was just like I man that
that's a lot of people you have to check
Holy fuck.
Can we see that emoji?
Okay, let me snip that emoji.
This is, like, the emoji I sent back.
I can, like, show it on stream now.
I, like, they were, like, being, like, man, I have to check
a lot of people.
And they gave me the number.
And I was like, bro.
And then I sent back.
Oh, wait.
Whoops, that's not it.
That is not it.
I need to, like, lock in this Fuggy so I don't
accidentally...
I don't accidentally move the Fuggy.
Okay, I need to, like, reset the...
Okay, I sent this picture back to them.
This is one of my favorite emojis.
I have, like...
Okay, I use a lot of emojis.
That's just pictures of my dog.
Okay.
Because my dog is so good at giving emotions.
Wait, let me...
I'll show you the other ones.
Wait, I need to, like, send myself these emojis.
Okay.
I have...
I have this one that is, like...
That is me yelling at people whenever...
This is my...
I have this one, too.
And then I also have...
I also have this one.
Uh...
Wait, I'll just...
I also...
I also have...
I also have this one.
I'm sorry.
My dog is just so good at showing emotion.
what can i say what can i say it's just so good so like i i
like all majority of time whenever people talk to me and i
use like emojis it's just all of it is just close up of my
dog's face because it's just so gay
it was like he was just born exactly it was like a point to
be a meme
in my team it's senox and uh he me oh wait we can give clips
guys fuck this sucks because i have no replay i'm not on
twitch we can't fucking show clips someone any youtube
editor right now any youtube clipper if you have it for
those who have been recording the stream if you have funny
videos of this stream upload it now and i could put it in
the because because you can also win money for having um uh
for having 1000 you can win a thousand dollars each person
for the two best clips clippers i know we don't have clips
but if you have a good clip from my stream please upload it
on youtube and like i don't know i actually Actually, please
figure out some way to send this clip to me.
Oh, use the hashtag.
I have a clip hashtag.
Use my clips hashtag.
Guys, we can win $1,000 so easily.
Use my hashtag, Doki Clips, for any of the Apex clips we've
made today.
and then and and then we can we can win win the vote we can
win the vote by sheer
okay we're not gonna cheat guys we're not gonna we're not
gonna it has to be actually funny guys so like challenges
we're gonna keep going to do keep the same card for world's
edge and then a new card for storm point so the challenges
are the same oh the challenges are the same does he mean
like the ones we've completed are like we don't have to
complete like we're keeping the same ones are we genuinely
just on the same card i think that's what everyone i think
like yeah i think everyone's asking that right now i think
uh i really meant like i guess like the challenges are the
same but they reset maybe someone is asking if they carry
over because if they do carry it would make sense to carry
over because like why have to play 90 fov every fucking game
please no please i feel like i feel like it shouldn't though
like to be to make it fair for everybody because like each
uh like you win a thousand five hundred for having the most
challenges and like the person the team with the most
challenges are ready from the first game we'll have yeah
they should reset yeah you're right It should because like
they would it would be so easy for them to finish a lot of
their challenges I don't even think he's answered anybody at
all.
I think he's thinking he's like wait this is a bad idea
Because he was making the card.
I was talking to him.
He was trying to make the card not prepared I think like
halfway like he he didn't think the game was gonna end that
fast while he was making the card
Thank you for the 50 gift and chips.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Also, yes, we don't have, like, emotes yet.
Because, like, I was, like, thinking, like, I felt like I
wanted to wait until my new skin suit was finished before we
have, before we upload new emotes.
I meant down to upload emotes of my dog.
Because I don't want to, like, I don't want to, like, waste
money and, like, have it remixed.
okay but yes oh we just do we just play valkyrie caustic
then if it's staying the same no matter what yeah we might
as well so we can get that yeah we might as well guys i can
play anyone but valk to be honest yeah i i cannot do valk so
i guess senox is just automatically on valk all right i'll
take gibby i can do caustic beautiful okay anyway okay if
you guys have the give me the i mean he hasn't even answered
anybody give me the links to the clip if it's the same card
we need to beat that one anyways on dokey clips wait what's
my hashtag again dokey clips and then i'll post those clips
into the clip channel guys guys guys come on if i win a
thousand dollars we all win guys guys we all win this
together i am blowing this man up so true it's a team effort
it's a team effort you win spiritually guys it's like we
both felt the win together um oh yes also might as well give
the update because like they're still trying to figure out
the whole fucking team scenario at the moment but basically
um basically
tomorrow it's not going to be Resident Evil 4 we're swapping
Resident Evil 4 with the who phobia who phobia stream do the
scheduling is because like the people I got Sayu and Amali
got fruit so um uh the schedule works better on Friday
instead of Saturday so on Friday we're playing with Amali
Sayu and fruit and then Saturday it's going to be Resident
Evil 4 uh it's only We swapped it because, like, there was,
like, it was the best scheduling-wise, uh, for, uh, no,
S-I-U, C-C-Y-Y-Y, wait, C-Y-Y-Y-U, the voice actor.
Okay.
Here, here, I'll type it down.
I know it got confusing It got confusing
Maybe it is a sigh Okay So So yeah I got sigh On my end and
Amon Lee got fruit So to match everybody's schedule Because
there was like four of us You know Saturday people uh people
would have like Saturday the schedule was conflicting for a
lot of us so uh we decided to swap it for tomorrow instead
of uh instead of Saturday so I just wanted to give you guys
the update for that everybody's just debating guys okay okay
so people there is a huge technical issue at the moment
because people are are debating right now about like whether
or not to reset the cards and everything uh oh wait okay um
all right so oh wait okay i'm looking at the update i'm
looking at the update right now we have to make a change to
a few challenges we're completed i was on wait what wait i
don't even wait i wasn't supposed to read that out
sorry i didn't answer it whoops sorry they're talking about
it right now they're still deciding they're still i'm sorry
i didn't mean i didn't leak anything i didn't leak anything
guys i didn't leak anything they're having a discussion
about whether or not the challenges stack or they are or
they would keep going so one of the biggest issue right now
is that there was 25 challenges but they didn't they thought
that we were gonna get 25 challenges or like close to 25
challenges and uh but we sort of uh the closest was 10
challenges so they're trying to decide right now if like
we're gonna keep the same card and seeing um and like just
whoever gets the most type deal because like no the closest
the team got was 10 challenges and not 25 because like 25
was a lot
okay let me let me see if anybody got me some dokey clips
that i can like spam of clips chat chat we have so many wait
no no we should not because i would divide the vote guys
don't divide the vote guys give me your best clips
i realize if we spend too many clips then it'll divide the
votes too fast so we have to send give me your best clips to
like we cannot divide the votes guys if if we we have to win
this together what close clips from this stream i know
there's no there's there's no rewind but i believe in you
i i believe in you guys clip master i need your strongest
clips right now because but guys Guys, but think of it this
way.
If we can technically win, because they're thinking, they're
like, oh, we might send it to like 500 per clip.
If we win all four of them, we can...
If we have all the four of the best clips, guys.
We can...
Guys, just think of this way.
best clips yeah we can win all of them you can't handle guys
i believe in you i believe in all of
you someone's like i feel so stupid right now trying to
understand all of this i'm just vibing i'm just vibing it's
been one hour we played one game
thinking of like dividing it by four so like instead of a
thousand each person um it's 500 per person so like if we
just have too many good clips we can technically get all of
them like we can how many games is six
it's it's it's six guys Don't worry.
We can be here for six hours.
We can do this.
I believe in us.
Okay.
Do not reuse the ones.
What?
Do not redo.
Oh.
Okay.
It stacks.
It's gonna stack.
It looks like it stacks.
Because it says do not reuse.
Do the ones you've already.
completed focus on completing the whole card seriously yeah
someone just said in chat i think they were watching on
stream so so it doesn't that's that's a bit unfair not gonna
lie
obviously all right same card for our world's edge oh we
wipe okay we wipe okay what the fuck why why is it different
from the person above okay so it's just fresh card it's the
same card but it wipes every game so we just do as many as
we can we wipe oh my gosh okay i like how the person again i
like how someone there was like so we start all over after
they were like do not redo the ones you're hitting completed
oh thank god okay so we want to do as many as we can for
free of it 90 fov three evo harvesters uh nades in a bag
three evacs or survival items I think we should knock
yourself draw heart no attachments alt three times that's
about it the other ones are at y'all I feel like we could
just do all that yeah we just we literally just lurk and do
nothing and wait okay we'll say Val you probably have to do
the nade one because we some big boys yeah I just do it the
nade one we can do that right off the bat and then like we
can have all we'll try and find as many alt excels as
possible and give it all to one person yeah that sounds
legit just all run a different sniper and whoever gets a
knock finishes the challenge.
Wait, who's doing the no survival items?
Let's survive the game.
Okay, I feel like- I guess it depends if we get- if we have
three evacs, we can do the three evacs.
If we don't, we can just do the don't use any.
I guess it just means something we get.
Wait, is the evac a survival item?
I thought that was like fields.
No, it's just- Chaos shields, mobi, and yeah, that's a
survival slot.
That's not health, is it?
No.
Wait, is it survival- wouldn't that just be a white heal
like why would they call it a survival item because it helps
you heal that's what i'm saying like what's a survival item
is survival item the heals or survival it's just the
survival because that's what they're called like yeah the
keybind is like mobile oh okay it's called survival item
okay okay so we just don't use we just don't care about that
one yeah um but unfortunately we have to choose if we want
to get that point or get the point of using three evac
towers at the same time i feel like whichever one comes
whichever one yeah we die before then then we technically we
you know just don't use any until we get through yeah okay
oh shit my dog is still on my stream um so we still we're
still on the tree right no we're countdown we're kind of oh
we're countdown now yeah okay i'm on We could go for the we
could go for the maybe where's Gibby.
Oh, you're not okay.
I guess we're not doing that then Okay, I'm okay.
We're I'm staying low, but then That is actually awful.
I didn't even know the game was started.
I was looking at the fucking Wait, can we get a restart?
No, no, you're good.
Can we get a restart?
Let's get a restart.
We see you crashed
Tell temple you're getting crashed
Okay.
Wait, and we got no beacon?
We are getting green.
I hate it here.
I'm already trying to do it in scrims.
Turn off your stream right now.
Okay.
Oh my god, when I just switched it to 90 FOB is zoomed in so
far.
Whoa.
Oh,
I mean, we don't have a beacon.
We just loot the POI and stack up.
all alt excels you can all three times still yeah i mean we
i mean we just didn't do the loba all because like loba all
is so fast yeah i can hit the button in the middle for you
guys yeah i'm just going to run over here and start loading
through yeah you can load all this i'll do this stuff
oh remember no attachments he me how could i forget that is
here's a try in theory you could technically do that one i
could just do the no attachments and then pick up the care
package no attachments.
Okay.
I'll just run sniper and pick up a carefactor Jones.
I've got a P20.
But that means no scopes, though, because it's not an
attachment.
It's alright.
Yeah, no scopes either, but.
Okay.
I'm trying to find more shield cells.
Well, it is pulling hard south.
Unfortunately.
Wait, can you give me your shield cells healing?
I can literally do the heart right now.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait.
This is actually harder than I expected.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to draw my shield.
Oh, do I.
That was the wrong mid.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Oh, what do I have to be?
A fragrant mid.
Here, here.
Jesus Christ.
Wait, I can do this.
No, I think I'll die if I do that.
No, you're good.
You're good.
It'll knock you no matter what.
You won't fall down.
You're right.
Oh, we got to go.
No, aren't you?
Fragrant in.
the skyhook team pulls up and kills us.
Oh my god wait this heart is harder than I expected.
Did you finish the heart?
Wait technically yes.
I need one shield cells.
Here I'll give you here.
Take this.
It's almost a heart.
Do it quick and then we gotta dip because we're about to
just die.
Okay wait wait.
Girl what is this?
It's technically a heart!
If you look at it correct.
Oh okay.
That's a heart and take screenshot that's a heart.
We've got to get it.
That's a heart.
Let's grab the support bin and then go for the beacon
fishery and that's a heart.
Did you take a screenshot?
We can just take it from the VOD.
We can take it from the VOD.
We are shambles.
We're no beacon too.
White armor.
Okay.
Let's hit the support bin.
There's no armor on the ground.
Let's just go for it.
We're just going to go for eva harvesters and stuff.
Okay.
We got the heart.
We have to like avoid people though because we have um We
have how many names do you guys?
I have almost bottom row.
zero nades like give me your backpack i can do it because i
don't have attachments anyway so i don't need i don't need
anything uh i can just and then you can drop me all your
nades i only need a couple i only need four more grenades
and then i can fix it i don't have let's go for the evil
harvester i have so many shield cells though i have some i
only have two yeah all right we have to avoid everybody we
can't fight right now wait what are the other things that we
need to do that's easy uh three evil harvesters grenades in
the backpack i have not found a single grenade here's one
grenade hold on i'm gonna grab this i can take it again i
can take it and i'll just transfer it over i'm heading over
to senai go fissure to hit beacon uh yeah but isn't there
somebody at fissure they hit the uav like oh no they're
still here back up back up yeah go for it pilot
interceptions we can play for we can play for this Play for
what?
What'd you say?
The eva harvester over here.
We need two more.
Okay.
I only need two more grenades and then I can actually pick
up one.
I have one here.
Here.
I'm looking everywhere.
And we can play for care packages too.
I just gotta remember not to pick up attachments.
I know.
I saw someone over there just now.
Yeah, let's go this way then.
I have zero white here.
We might just be sitting in zone off the game.
I'm not gonna lie.
There's a vault here.
We've got this vault.
We're fighting up here.
We might be doing a third party this.
Yeah, that's smart.
I'm just gonna try to knock one with Sentinel and get the
challenge.
Yeah, I'll just say is that smart to- They're moving back.
I'm moving to you.
They're coming in.
They're coming.
Yeah, I'm running.
Go, go on side.
Go on side.
I got Volky.
Okay, okay.
I don't even have ammo right now.
gonna say like i don't know go right there's somebody in the
there's somebody riding in this rv yeah yeah that sounds
right just keep going i can't see guys we're gonna we're
gonna go for the i can't fucking see oh they're here they're
here they're here they might look at us let's go this way
this is awful huh i i i need two more grenades again i can
throw my you can just see.
We're actually just and passive as challenge.
Let's see.
No nades, no nades.
Maybe here?
No nades.
Oh.
Oh my god, I got it.
I got it.
We just got there.
Run, run, run, run, run.
I don't have anything.
I don't have any loot.
Back up, back up.
We leave.
I'm gonna port.
Play on the trailer and stay healthy.
Okay.
Tell me if I need to drop it.
I'm looking.
I don't see them yet.
We're gonna have to just run in a zone because I don't have
loot to fight.
Bloodhound ults.
Yeah, I'm dropping it now.
They're to my left.
There's a guy above us in countdown.
Come right, come right, come right.
Whoa!
Wow, this is scary.
We have to go far.
This is so scary.
We're just a little, little rat.
How many, how many White Hills do you have?
I have, I can give you some.
I have two Med kits as well.
Yeah, Force Renix in.
No, we just have to loot these on.
Wait, we can use you all here.
You have enough like to sustain for a little bit, yeah.
isn't there like i'm gonna go grab the evil harvester you
might as well use your alt to get like one of the other yeah
yeah you can spam yours if you want you can pop it up there
or wherever it doesn't matter i'm stuck no yeah let's go to
let's go to monument okay i'm gonna need some uh white hills
from here though or from somebody uh you can give it to him
i have like four syringes and one phoenix kit okay i have
three syringes give you a couple i have zero we just need to
get little rats I'm just gonna run for now and just gotta at
least I can pick up loot now true rats rats we are the rats
this is like the most the poorest I've ever been in apex
legends yeah this is awful are you are you entertained chat
okay Senox here's how these changes thank you oh I have a
med kit oh just one what is the that's fine that's fine what
i can give you one piece we we get we get it off of this evo
we get the oh keep right in front of us okay this is oh i
hope not well i'm just chilling this is i'm not peeking i'm
just gonna let i'm chilling in this corner running right now
they're going left choke when all right we need to have
another alt and also grab that harvester and then we should
yeah i'm going for the harvester right now we gotta we gotta
work to zone because we don't have enough white meds to say
they're shooting wait i heard someone's shooting i'm gonna
go for the right here right here yeah i'm gonna grab this
and then come back should we just go train side yeah i had
to drop the valkyrie i didn't even get to pick it up i had
to grab the nades i don't even know we have enough yeah
let's check harvester i think we have to go through
harvester with 30 seconds there is a team to our left though
they uh was it the one that valkal did they yeah there was a
valkal but i think they were shooting at someone okay just
be careful right i still don't even have ammo this is awful
wait what ammo do you need Oh my gosh, you have the most
niche ammo too.
Like, I would love to help you.
Shotgun.
Oh, yeah.
No.
I can't use guns with attachments.
My old son, it's an 80.
Yeah, let's go harvester and the bolt.
And then I'll have port.
We got to try to port in the zone and survive.
I guess we don't use any survival items.
We don't have an either.
But do you have your another alt yet, Amy?
Not yet.
I just said 80.
Oh, 80?
Okay, the moment you do it, just chuck it there and then
mark it off.
Let's go throw on med kits on the crafter.
place out because there might be someone here but i'm gonna
close the door so we know can we hit the could you hit the
beacon maybe so we get purple yeah hang in all right guys
yay we have our all two they might know we're here now
though but we can mark that off this was my third alt right
yeah that's the third one yeah that's third all right
fighting behind here fighting Yeah.
All right.
Let's work towards, uh, we gotta get in a zone.
We're gonna die, we're shambles.
I'm gonna grab a med kit there just in case.
Yeah, I'm throwing on a med kit.
Actually, I need to throw on a bat.
I don't have any shield heals either.
I can jump you back.
There's another low ball to a right.
I'm throwing on, throw on some meds then we should get
going.
This team might try to gatekeep us, so I'm gonna go ahead.
Whoop.
Does my P20 need no attachments or it doesn't matter?
Oh, no, you can have attachments because, uh, Okay, okay,
okay.
Cool.
I didn't know if the P20 had to be naked.
Careful, there was people on the right.
They might be walking up.
Flying over us.
Two teams flying in.
Coming, coming, coming.
On bridge, they're on bridge, on bridge.
Whoa.
Wait, there's a, there's an evil harvester.
That's the last evil harvester.
We already got, we already got three.
We already got three?
I thought we got two.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we have three.
I didn't know any of them.
You see where these people are above us?
No.
I didn't, we needed to just get on.
They know they landed on bridge though is all.
I'm walking up, someone look at the bridge when we get up
here.
Please.
I'm gonna try to smash the whole area.
They're on the platform.
Yeah.
Ooh, they ulted too.
You see anybody in this building?
There's a team there.
There's another team that redeployed to the bridge too.
There's another team on bridge.
Just right, just right, just right.
These guys, they're my fight and we're gonna have to throw
it.
There's a lot of people everywhere.
And we don't have any networks.
I saw them run it from redeployed to the bridge.
Do you have, do you have cells?
Yeah, do you need?
I want to charge this because it's my only gun.
They're trying to get those charged senties off.
We might have to just hug Logan and run underneath them.
You have, like, no time.
I still have a fort, so.
No team is dying, though.
That's the scary part.
It's still right in front of us.
These guys aren't moving.
Just go left.
You're waiting, too.
but they're all waiting and they're just gonna velko we
don't have bulk though this is awful
it's just right in the rv come in the rv and come in the rv
and right come in the rv and right nothing good has happened
since the start here's some shield cells yeah we got the all
let's go we're just gonna have to run in last second and i'm
gonna pray i can hit like the goat or something don't help
marion is there nobody can we can we move forward here all
in on senox right there might be a team in this building so
we just gotta go together all right all in i'm running
forward and going for a part i'm running forward and going
for a part all right i don't even know i'm gonna be able to
get it to be honest but it's okay i fully trust you i stop
trusting i stop trusting i'm dropping here for now you can
take it we're starting to see if you can you get a gen down
we i think we're getting here we have to we have to shoot
this we have to shoot on my on my ping.
I'm jenning.
You're right here.
Shoot the shoot the shoot the shoot the.
This team's on right as well.
I got him I got him.
I got him.
He's resing though.
He's resing.
We have to kill this.
We have to kill that team.
We'll just wait for them to get a bubble.
I'm looking looking for you.
Trying to cancel that.
Okay to here.
They're running.
Oh no, I took your bubble.
Oh no.
In the corner right here 80.
Yeah.
I'm looking.
I'm seven.
I'm throwing all my arcs in that corner.
Whoa.
Can we do this?
My little shield.
I'm farming.
I'm farming them.
We can kill these guys.
Flash, flash, flash.
He's flashed.
Cracked one?
Cracked another one.
Oh my god.
I just took it.
Where?
I'm at your point.
it's horrible, bro.
And it just ran out.
No, and it's out!!
I'm cute.
I'm good.
No, fuck you way.
Do you have low ball?
I'm gonna pop all the cells to court.
Yeah, no, no, no.
We have to just, play to kill them.
This guy, look at them.
Look at him.
Shoot the fuck out.
Oh, I couldn't get it.
I got like...
I almost cracked it.
Do you have low-ball maybe?
No, yeah, no.
There's a team above us.
Team above us.
Yep.
Wait, I don't need this, maybe.
I have port, I have port.
Okay, I'm pro- Oh, this sucks.
There's actually so many people.
I don't see a team directly.
Are they just in here, riding?
Like, where are they?
I heard footsteps.
I can't- I'm gonna go scout it.
I'm gonna go scout it.
Let's just all go together.
They're right here.
They're just jumping out.
jumping down on the left.
We can just mirror this.
Yeah, yeah.
They scanned it.
I might have to port up through here and just get a port in
a lower launch, maybe.
So I think they're holding the round.
Yeah, they're hard holding.
We got to go around.
We have to go now.
No.
I'm going to bat and then port from the corner.
There's a team in this building, okay?
Up here?
There definitely is.
All right, good luck.
Actually, just run it.
Just run it.
I think they're all going to buckle.
Jesus Christ.
Come off, come off, come off, come off.
There's a lot of barrels.
Oh, I'm going to drop a horn up here for you.
Gun for this.
All right.
Do you have Jen?
No.
I vote.
Okay.
You have to come and instantly look right.
Instant look right.
There's a team on our right.
Come on our right.
Try to Jen if you have it soon.
I don't.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
We try to, we watch the walk in and then we try to look left
at the third party and get some kills.
A full team's going to walk up right here.
We have to be the one to climb.
I'm looking.
It's a full team behind us right here as well.
Behind this rock.
They're shooting the rock now.
Rocked on?
Right here.
They killed the team.
This rock, this rock, this rock.
Okay, I'm looking at this.
I'm looking at this rock.
There's a team riding in this corner right here.
We might have to go kill them.
Or directly above us.
We're not scans above 95%.
Can you level up?
Yep.
Yeah.
Sold us.
Oh my god.
Care package guns.
I'm just grabbing both.
Okay, we need to look to kill them.
I think there's still a team riding above us.
They're sitting in this corner right above us.
I have all.
You want, I'm not all.
Do you have any nades?
No, no nades.
You look in the, there's nades here.
I've got, I have gold knocked.
I have gold knocked.
Here, here.
Here's a nade.
I want to drop this.
Drop the knock.
Riding in this corner.
Can we try to kill them?
Okay, someone grab this knock.
Uh, I got it.
Thank you.
I threw an aid here for you.
Any alt excels?
Can I get called Helmet?
Yeah, here.
I'm going to grab the innate.
Any alt excels?
I'm not going to have port.
Yeah, I've got one here.
Nope, I don't have any.
Yeah, I'm just going to go for another port and we're going
to have to pray it's fucking decent.
Maybe you can't try to see me kidnap somebody.
Can we wrap the logon and try to kill this team?
They're sitting like right in this corner.
Oh, there's a team right above.
I'm going to port.
I mean, if you want to just go for the kidnap.
Oh, true.
Just like it.
We both said true as well.
I mean, that's like...
Okay, take part, take part, take part.
Okay.
Instantly peek the corner man.
There's a team sitting here.
They're good.
Hug the wall.
We're safe here.
They're evacing right above us.
Just look up.
Just get a knock on here.
We gotta get a knock on here.
Yeah, we can look.
We can look.
Just wait for zone to close.
I'm marking it.
They have to take it up and we have to knock.
They're gonna peek above us.
The only place they kill us is above.
I'm gonna make sure nobody takes our port.
oh my god they're just still sitting with us though they
have costa took part took part
i don't know about this above oh i'm getting oh no i'm
caring i'm caring i can't wait the moment i turn around from
the portal too
it's case the knocks live is that considered a kidnap he's
finishing me oh no he's giving me the finishing wait should
i go pop a finish on this on this guy yes yes you should yes
you should wait his teammates on them no it's okay just get
like just try and get anything i don't they're pressing it
they're pressing it i have no dude i have no meds and no
ammo it's okay just get a knock if you can you know now that
we're dead we can start marking off stuff on the card oh
that is a good good spot Oh no.
Oh no.
Don't burn.
Don't look.
If they can't see you, you can't see them too.
Oh wait, yeah.
We got the one with the care package gun kill because I
killed that lifeline.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Care package gun kill.
Unfortunately, not looking too good.
We didn't use a survival item.
Oh, true.
I got the knock.
We got the heart three times.
I'm going to go for the kidnap for the point.
Okay.
I'm going to shut up and count.
Where are they?
I got him.
Yes.
Kidnap.
We did it.
Wait, did you actually?
It's okay.
We got the kidnap.
Okay.
So hang on.
I count one.
So from the top, we got FOV, three EVA harvesters, nades.
You only had two care pack weapons, right?
So we didn't have three.
Did you guys have it?
No.
No, I didn't.
Okay.
You didn't get any knocks.
sniper did you no i got one shot so kid got the frag knock
got the shield cells got the no attachments and got the old
three times knock with the care package and you got the
knock with the care package that's nine we did the heart did
we get the heart yeah yep okay heart oh nice good job damn
if we had one more care i don't think we got i mean 10 10
was the winning the winning last time yeah yeah but like i
think now people know but this time people didn't play comp
so yeah yeah people already know like uh like what to do
though yeah all right did we not get we didn't get any
knocks at the p20 right no oh unlucky no i shot at the
lifeline but i think you got that one which is still a win
that's unlucky yeah we're team six we got nine yeah typing
that was very satisfying
1420.
Not a joke.
I've ever played like a more shambles Apex Legends game.
That was that was so rough.
We I felt like you know it was going to be rough when you
know we already picked the wrong characters.
I know it was wraps after that honestly that one the the the
fuck up got us got us two points though we got the the care
package and the the kidnap.
That's true that's true but that was like honestly the most
skeptical game I've ever played.
Somebody got 11 down.
Oh, it was third.
Even though, like, that doesn't mean we win anything.
But we.
Oh, wait, no, no, no.
They didn't get 11.
They got the team 11 that got seven.
Seven team 11.
Well, that team got 10 anyways, unfortunately.
Yeah.
We were like one one.
We're in the top percentile.
Like, we got nine.
Like, good stuff, guys.
honestly they were easy they were not too bad to do in the
poi before we leave were we kind of in shambles without the
rotate yes but yeah i think it was smart to just do all the
challenges on the poi and then start leaving for like
because everybody's val everybody was val so like it didn't
hurt us rotating because everyone was just about rotating
out there's actually so many teams on edge almost every
single team just sits in their poi doing the challenges yeah
everybody almost every team had nine i guess we gotta we for
the last game we need to try to like do the ones quick and
then we i think we should look for uh a third party so we
can get the like the knocks with the guns and then like uh
because we can stick a down person too and then finish them
that would have been a lot oh yeah one of us gave one of us
gave that one team a finisher yeah gibby's ass sat on me bro
Just need...
Okay, I can do the heart again.
It's so... I didn't realize how that.
I forgot, like, the shield cells.
They can go anywhere.
That's the worst part.
My little scuffed heart.
Guys.
Why was the heart a challenge?
I thought, like, I was like, oh yeah, that's easy.
I can, like, just put down my shield.
And I was like, wait.
Wait a minute.
You cannot just put down your shoes.
You see the...
I mean, like, if we're talking about abstract here, like,
abstract-wise, it sort of looked like a heart.
Oh, my God.
That was...
That was fucking rough.
I think I spent, like, like, 80% of the time in that...
in our poi just try to make that fucking one heart
it's a modern art a team got 13.
holy shit what the fuck did you do we have one team that had
13.
well it's okay top five i think i mean from three from three
to like uh to not Nine points?
That's pretty good.
Top five.
No, no, no, no.
Just top five.
Spam sales and then remove to get the heart.
Okay, but then you'll find enough sales for that.
The hardest part was I did not have enough sales for that.
That was the hardest part.
Improvement, exactly.
Every game we improve.
that's all that matters.
If every game we improve a little little bit, then that's
all that matters.
Epi Center?
Oh my, okay.
We have Survey 2.
Oh my God.
That's pretty good.
Yeah, that would have.
I thought it was just Epi.
That's pretty good.
Epi Survey.
What's the loop path?
One person Survey.
One person Epi.
One person Skyhook Tunnel.
Skyhook Tunnel.
Oh!
Well, that's what it is in Comp.
I don't know if people will.
well i mean everybody has like one pro player i guess
everyone has their their set drop spots too yeah i can do
the tunnel uh just in case there's people up there i can
just run away with some and then one person epic and
wherever the beacon is you just land on oh my gosh we're
gibby caustic valc so i don't really have a preference um on
where do you mind woodoki where you land i don't mind i
don't really have a preference caustic just go ep  if
there's beacon yeah oh yeah i'll just go to the beacon
Should I do the no attachment one again?
Okay, FB.
I'll go where the beacon.
I had to make the P20 for most of that game.
I feel like the P20 person should have the no attachments in
the end.
That's what I feel like, too.
I feel like it's just easier to like justify.
You do the attachments.
I'll do the grenade one then.
Okay.
Like hold all the nids.
Yeah, yeah, that sounds good.
Yeah, that sounds good.
And then I make the heart.
I feel like I'm going to waste most of my time trying to do
that.
No, you're actually different on it now.
From the one game, you like practice.
You're right.
I have the experience now.
It should be easy.
Guys, where are my clips?
Guys, where am I?
Where am I?
Guys, you can't say clip that.
I still don't see any clips in the dokey clips.
In the dokey clips hashtag.
too busy watching so just gonna run a sniper every game and
try to knock somebody do something but what do you mean my
entire existence is funny this is why i'm a streamer my
entire life is a joke oh too real too real all right we have
i feel like hey we're faster now hour a game it is 30, 40
minutes a game where we're like cutting down our time.
We're speed running this chat.
That's great.
Thank God.
We made it pretty far though.
I don't think I can play like a six hour.
I don't think I can do six hours.
If you get a good zone because you can just do all the
things sitting in zone and then you just get everything else
done because you're just in God's spot.
I guess public people and stuff.
Don't heal a Joker.
Take your time.
But yeah, we still have we still have four more games left
chat these like it's just scary because like everybody's not
dying that's like the scariest part nobody is fucking dying
so like everybody is just trying to try to do their
challenges and I'm just like please spare me please please
spare us let us go let's This is N-Apex.
What do you mean nobody is dying?
We actually just weren't passing them.
What do you mean no one's dying?
This is N-A-Apex.
At least spare.
Three care pack weapons and three red armor.
Yeah, we weren't lucky enough to get the three red armor.
Oh my god, so money had one.
Thank god that wasn't me.
Guys, I told you we're in.
Improving.
We didn't have one.
Look at us.
We're getting better and better.
I think there's some teams that don't even put their points
because they're like, what's the point?
They didn't.
Oh my god.
Not last.
We're in set.
Top five.
That's what I like.
These relaxing moments between rounds.
Yeah, this is nice to It's nice.
I it's nice, but then like sometimes I wish it wasn't too
long, you know, I just I Let me play the game.
Let me play the game.
I just want to play, please Let me play.
Oh my gosh, like yesterday I was so stressed the fuck out
yesterday that I mostly just I was mostly just like sleeping
I was so fucking I was just so fucked up man
I was like I didn't get any work done and then like one of
the things I had to do that was due yesterday I got like a
message about it they're like um Doki we're sort of behind
schedule and I was
so sorry i'm so sorry i was i was so relaxed i was like i
was so busy yesterday i i was so tired i just wanted to
sleep i didn't say that i just said i was so busy yesterday
with behind the scenes work i'm so sorry and then i like i
can get it done today i'm so sorry i'm behind schedule but
they understand and i got i sent i sent this stuff that had
to do Right before I had to start my stream.
I'm so sorry I'll never sleep again.
Let's see.
Wait, each and advances to the final...
Oh, wait, what?
Wait, they changed the rules.
If you win for most challenges per game, you advance to the
final.
finals.
I thought it was overall.
Yeah, we just have to get the most in one game.
The top team that wins the challenges for that game gets to
advance.
Yeah.
Yeah, I thought it was like I thought it was overall, but it
seems like... Yeah, but now... Well, it's actually like too
good for us for that three, the three.
At least that actually doesn't count.
We just have to...
So if you win just like one of them, you can go to the
finals.
Yeah.
So we got uh you just need like we gotta start getting some
of these like actual fighting ones the challenges we need to
fight yes anox you need to i actually it was physically
impossible to fight people i had i had four set levels i had
four set levels and no attachments that you expect us to get
the fighting one i know i felt so bad like you were feigning
for that lobo all i was like no it's not ready they were the
babies here you're supposed to carry us i need to not do the
the no-intachment ones you guys yeah exactly i would decide
don't worry i was hoping to just get a no attachments one um
dokey wait me yeah i feel like you haven't been nerfed
enough yet like i'm but like you're on the p20 though yeah
but my other gun doesn't get attachments either i don't know
i mean that plus 90 is rough oh but oh but you can you can
just run the vault you don't need attachments on the vault
it's so easy to be nerfed a little bit to like join no i
mean i am nerfed i'm making the heart i'm making the heart
is a very hard thing to do like i can't loot when i'm making
the heart that's practically a nerve right there yeah yeah
yeah yeah i mean no this all in all this is like the senox's
decision it's all up to me why am i the leading because
you're the igl you're i just want to be the content You're
the, I'm the content creator.
I too am a content creator.
I don't know what he's talking about.
What do you mean?
Okay, okay, no, no, no.
I'm pretty sure I'm the more content creator compared to
you.
I'm pretty sure.
If we look at stats here regarding our stream on Apex, I
just started two weeks ago.
So I have released our stream for Apex.
i don't know i don't stream apex i'm a content creator i
just don't stream at all i create content but like i don't
put it out you literally have a liquidpedia that invalidates
everything you say i couldn't even get a liquidpedia anybody
can get one of those no i try to get what and they deleted
my liquidpedia because my tournaments are not official
enough they deleted my liquidpedia so i know that's a lie
They're like, your tournaments are too much on content
creation and not pro enough.
Nobody can outsmart me.
Weird flex.
It's true!
People try to make me a liquipedia.
It's a nice little zone.
We just sit there.
They like deleted it.
10 billion damage.
Get airdrops.
Yeah.
I just got here.
Did we win?
Maybe, like, mentally, we've won.
We've won the mental battle.
That's all that matters.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't... The other things don't matter.
We win the mental battle.
All right, remember to pick your legends this time.
Oh, shit.
Custic.
Oh, my God.
Good call.
Nice.
We got one point already.
We did it.
Nice.
Our one point.
Go, ass.
All right, we got this.
Beacon?
No beacon?
We don't need beacon.
That's fine.
uh yeah one one person epi one person i'll do i'll do the
tunnel just in case just be careful epi actually no you
should be good i don't think the comments okay i'm gonna go
to epi then dude up meet up and survey all right so i don't
gotta move perfect yeah you get to stay there i mean you
want to swap i don't mind if you need i'm gonna turn this
into a home over here you know i'm free to swap with you out
of the goodness with my heart you'll find me churning butter
by the time you guys get here okay i hope i don't die that's
don't die all i hope for you'll be fine just like talk to
him nicely yo i'm getting ratted this guy is a freak all
right guess i'm coming to see the epi hey you already got
you already lost your home what happened the skyhook guy
landed on me and i didn't get a gun oh okay fight him are
you scared I don't have a blaster.
I don't have a gun.
Oh, you got the gun first.
Damn, no beacon sucks.
I hope you guys grab all the shield cells.
Oh yeah, I have three nades on me right now.
Um, I only have...
I have three on me.
And also blue backpack.
We can just stack nades and then drop them all to one
person.
Yeah.
Yep.
That's the plan.
I'm gonna go up.
See if there's anything.
They're pushing us.
They're entering us.
Wait, what?
I have to pop a saw.
Already?
I think so.
Trying to come link with you.
He's sitting in the building.
Wait, what is this guy doing?
Do I come over or leave?
Yeah, you should come over.
You should come over.
I'm heading over now.
Oh, my God.
I have no shield hills.
I'm flying on the rock.
They're walking up.
I don't know when we're shot on the back of the building.
Popping soldiers.
Where are they?
I only see Gibby right now.
He was on the building.
I see him.
They're running up.
I'm popping soldiers.
What the hell?
I saw one.
Yeah.
This guy.
Shoot the Gibby.
Can't see you.
No other way out there.
Wait.
What is this guy doing?
He's actually just like trolling and playing for fun.
Wait, what?
He went up.
Yeah.
Are we good?
Yeah, we're good.
All right.
anyone have a blue bag I have blue bag yeah do you want my
need to go craft a bat I have a Vulcan wait can you guys
give me your shield cells I'm gonna make the heart now I
have zero okay only have four all right I'm gonna try and do
this okay I will attempt this play for let's go grab this
evil in the tunnel and then let's hit the balloon and go for
the vault.
We have to play slow anyways, we didn't get bacon,
unfortunately.
Here's four.
This can be a heart.
It is!
It looks like a heart!
It does...
Yes!
Look!
Like that!
Okay, I need... I need...
I need Sennox to come over your screen.
It looks like a heart!
If it looks like it's fine, it doesn't have to be perfect.
It is!
Okay, there you go.
We did it.
That's hard enough.
Yeah, let's go up here and hit the evo.
And then we're gonna go for the vault.
I can vault call back there.
Do we have enough nades to do the nade bag thing?
I have three right now.
I have three.
I don't think.
Let's just all hold each other, like nades until we have
enough so one person isn't like scuffed.
Wait, you have nine on you?
We have enough.
Yeah.
369 is a full bag?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll do it up here on the balloon.
I'll give you the nades and then go grab the and come back
what they're riding in here what are these guys doing well
then i guess we don't do that they're so cringe here just do
it under here i guess i'm gonna i'm gonna drop all the nades
and then go away all right i'm gonna drop all of this in
don't take my stuff please you're just throwing everything
up he's walking up he's walking up i'm slowing down okay if
he's walking up.
I can't do this anymore.
He took my nades.
Oh, they're above us.
Yeah, I threw my nades away.
You come back to me on the bubble or no?
Okay, okay.
Um, so we left a bunch of nades on that ground.
I picked up one of them.
I picked up, I have four.
Is it a solo Givby?
It's not.
No.
Almost cracked Givby.
Givby's one.
I have to heal.
Not Givby.
Oh, nice.
You got the knock.
They're gonna rock.
Let's just back up.
I don't have Liu.
Let's just go.
Let's just go to the vault.
Come to me and I'm gonna Valkalt behind this building.
Wait, was that one of the challenges?
The knock?
Bro, it's a new team.
Can we get the building?
No, Bob, no, Bob, no, Bob.
They're trying to port.
They're trying to get up.
We're going to try to revalco.
We got to get out of here.
Come to me.
All right, we're here.
Outside, outside.
Yay.
This...
We're going to fly front and go to the Skyhook vault.
We have to play for evil harvesters.
all right pick me a longbow or a sentinel i guess i can pick
up a different gun all right
do we have one evil harvester right we don't we don't have
it yeah we do i got one i got one okay perfect yeah i did
let's uh let's hit this vault and get this one back here we
can play for red armor if we get the vault all right i'm
dropping a gold light maker they're just gonna keep wking as
we stay here yeah it might be a team that already got the
challenges so they're just playing for kills like they could
go ready is 20 squads up there's no way oh no you win one of
the one of the the games you don't oh there's no point so
they're just yeah they're just playing to kill people
unfortunately because they advance to the finals already
yeah they just get to relax tell me that's not cursed that
guy's getting that guy's gonna get a talking to after this
game if that's cursed oh yeah uh gold is here huge remember
no attachments me yeah oh wait whoa no attack just throw it
out Maybe you haven't used it and yet yet I haven't used it
Be careful.
Can we get on this roof?
They might land on us.
We might have to fight them here.
I'm gonna fly roof We're good.
We're good.
How many naysayers do you guys have?
I only have four of two I have six seven eight.
Okay, we need two gonna go craft a bat Okay, just scrap loot
and we're gonna play for the evos and stuff Wait, there's I
need a valkalt two more times.
Yeah, I need a valkalt two more times I'm only popping one
so far.
I'm going to grab this evil harvester.
Yeah.
Grab the evil harvester and then, um...
Are you...
Wait, so I'm the one that's doing no attachments.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, you're the one with no attachments.
Can you...
You want to hit beacon?
Uh, yeah, I can.
Yeah.
I'm going to run right now.
I just want to see if I can find some names.
I haven't seen any.
I have two right now.
I have four.
We have a minute.
We're going to hit beacon and get going.
We need one more evil armor, sir.
We need six more nades.
Beacon, I'm going to peek in the countdown.
This is gap above us, gap above us.
We're going to Valcalf, we're going to Valcalf.
We're going to go out, but we can come back here.
I've been 5%.
Do we have enough nades to do the nade one quick?
I have five.
Oh yeah, five?
I have five now.
Okay, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
We need three, we need three more.
I have two.
Yeah, yeah, I counted yours.
There's another one up here.
So we need two more.
I can grab one right now.
There you go.
I'm going to grab this one.
You grab it?
Okay.
Let's go, uh, let's try to do it in this building so we can
vault and like actually pull the game.
All right, we need two more nades and we should be good.
So I need another sniper too.
No nades.
Nope.
All right, whatever.
Let's, uh, let's vault go here.
I'm not even sure.
going to be open there's still 19 teams let's play for we
might just play for the tracks i don't know if we can get
them around just go last slide for now we can hit this evil
harvester and get our third one there's a guy there's a guy
there there's a team does he have teammates yeah yeah yeah
all four yeah wait there's a team in one side go count down
go count down do we have any health excels nope no okay my
last syringe and you said up now i have another need right
here can you hold this uh that means we need one more yeah i
can hold it i can hold it okay let's look for one more and
then get going just need one more
i'm gonna scout do we see anybody mirage i'll look around
see we can find one more need we might look to play a top
mirage if we can oh there's no nades in here let's get going
we're on bridge Was I a third Valhalla?
No, we need one more.
We need one more.
There's a caustic trap in this valley.
Watch out.
There's nades here.
There's nades.
We have enough nades here.
I'm dropping all my nades.
I just dropped all your nades there and I'll just do it.
We gotta hurry up.
Yeah, I'm picking up white meds.
Hey.
They flew in.
I didn't even drop it.
Yeah, they did.
On the balcony right now.
Okay, can you drop yours?
I have white meds.
Yeah, do all the nades on these bodies are here really
quick.
And then we're gonna run out.
Alright, I'm dropping my nades.
I got it!
Yeah, let's go quick.
You can pick up all your loot.
We gotta go.
You gotta, do you need white meds?
I'm dropping a med kit and four surges in here.
I have med kits.
I'm good.
Yeah, we're gonna, we're gonna be looking for, we might
slide down and grab this and then try to play.
We're gonna have to play slow.
All right.
Is there anyone in graveyard in front of us?
I don't think so.
There's a harvester right there.
Yeah, let's play for this fence right here.
I'll grab the evo.
We can just go straight to the fence.
There's a team top mirage there.
So be careful.
Might beam you.
Oh yeah, they're looking.
You bubble it if you have to.
We finished our...
Do you have any syringes?
I only have med kits.
I'm dropping a Phoenix if you don't pop that.
Careful, they might need some of us.
We're not going to bubble here.
They're right above us.
I'm good.
I'm just going to mythic then.
We're going to have to...
We're going to use our third Velcro to get in the zone.
Okay.
Do you want to buff for it?
This is my last meds, by the way.
Oh, here.
I can give you a couple shield heals.
No, I don't...
No, my last like...
I can give you some.
What kind of heals do you need?
I just need syringes.
I don't have any...
I dropped three.
Wait, what?
Nading us, hitting us.
Bubble, bubble, bubble, bubble, bubble.
Oh, I hope it's in time.
I hope it's in time.
I'm playing back here.
I'm playing back.
We played to kill this thing.
Just play to kill this thing.
Can you maybe crawl to the back of this?
I don't know.
Oh, I can't.
This all is not your all, question mark.
Just keep crawling.
We can play res.
20 seconds on Bob.
Like, what's going on?
I don't know.
One died.
Popping a bat.
Can you play Res?
Just play Res.
We have to Res and lock all that.
I'm gonna drop my gold.
She should get 50.
I'm here.
I'm dropping gold Res, but I'm dropping gold Res.
Oh, they snatched that shit.
Wait, Lilba snatched it.
Lilba snatched it.
We gotta pray they don't team us.
Oh my God.
That's so unlucky.
That is so unfortunate.
to the zone.
Oh, okay.
You survive.
I'll bub as soon as he drops.
Do you need to?
We have to just fly far and we might drop down into lava.
I think I might just die.
Oh, we're good.
Can you bubble instantly?
Bubb, bub, bub, bub.
Come on, bitch.
I'm Phoenixing.
We play this platform and we might have to drop down into
the lava.
I'm not sure yet.
Third harvester in front.
I don't have any.
We already got it.
Okay.
I don't have any healments.
Slide forward and then we have to look at her back.
Slide forward and look minus.
All right, I'm looking.
Loba, old.
LOS suspense.
And we got to look behind us.
Do any of you guys have?
Yeah, yeah, here.
Get on the ground.
Behind, behind, behind, behind.
In the corner, 120.
I can get it.
It's a solo Loba.
I'm just going med kit.
I'm going med kit.
I can't.
How long on, how long on next bubble?
10 seconds, 10 seconds.
Okay, we're going to swing wide and bubble and kill the Loba
on the cart.
I'm making need this.
Three, two.
Let's go, let's go.
one one one oh he fucked up what dead nice loot it and we
gotta go back he's the one that took the she's the one that
took that shit she's the one that took it here i got it here
i can oh you got they're shooting at you they're shooting
any alt excels no i can just give this okay we have any bats
oh my gosh where am i getting shot i have i have a bat i
drop a bat okay grabbing some cells on the ground i'm just
looking for i need these cells bud hey wait i can reach in
my hp right here.
Wait, did you ever knock yourself with the frag?
Oh.
No, we haven't.
Do you want to do it right now?
Oh my God.
Here, here's a frag.
Here's a regular frag.
I'm going to do it.
Take the gold resin, isn't it?
But... Okay.
You should do it.
You should take it.
Oh my God.
I thought you were going to be...
The building, the building.
Oh my God.
Wait, we actually might have just...
We have to slide up to their fence, okay?
Slide to the fence, slide to the fence, slide to the fence.
They're right close, they're right close.
We're playing, so we're gonna play slow.
No, he couldn't.
I have gold rest.
You have gold.
No, I'm dead.
I never, you gave me gold.
That's fine.
They're on you.
I was too thick.
I don't even think we live, I'm not gonna lie.
We were too thick.
Oh my god.
Bad idea to drop.
It's okay, I can watch.
like a couple of seconds it's okay how many times did we
welcome uh i think that was that was our third that was our
third yeah that was our third we should be fine i'm gonna
play for a longbow knock and a finisher i think that's too
thick there
is so many people oh
my gosh i just realized
I don't think... Do you have enough shields?
Oh, you do.
Oh, my God.
Do you have enough meds for this?
No, I'm probably just bad.
I'm out of shield deals.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I think there's a rock I can sit by.
I might just walk all and go for that.
Oh, let's see if you make it.
I mean, surely I'm dead if I just stay here.
I'm out of meds.
That's true.
Yeah, you might as well...
This is your last... Your hell, Mary.
Oh my god, it's in.
Holy fuck, it's in.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There's only one sniper shot.
No.
Oh.
Oh my god.
You're not in, though.
I think I can climb up a little bit.
I'm out of meds, so.
I'm going to wait.
I'm going to wait till that second.
All right.
We got a cheese, a longbow knock.
OMG.
Oh my god.
I can't believe this is happening.
You're like, you're like one shot away from dying.
There's, oh no!
I just hope no one looks at you.
Oh my gosh.
Do you have any heals?
No, I'm fully out.
No!
It's not!
Why?
What was that?
Zeroed them.
Bro, it's OOV down there.
I thought I could boost her up, but it's OOV and you can't
boost her at OOV.
One, two, three, four.
That's so jove.
Five, six, seven, eight.
I didn't know that was OOV, honestly.
That's like...
did we get nine again we got nine okay i actually i had to
recount because we actually got 10 i forgot to count we
didn't use a survival item oh it was actually 10 last game
so i had to recount to make sure okay someone fact-check me
someone fact-check me for this one what number you guys have
all right i'll put the picture up i don't even think because
i need what are the challenges could we could i have done
that game just the longbow knock where i knock somebody yeah
the longbow let's see we didn't have our comp last game
right or did we no we didn't we didn't we did this game okay
so we got that i mean you could have got 3 000 just to keep
four yeah just a little a little 2 000 damage just a little
farmer yeah uh you could you could've got the knock opponent
off evac tower uh one player drops a 2k damage game uh get
10 kills or more as a team and you're the team oh my god
it's okay we're consistent that's that's we're we're
improving was it nine it was a nine i thought it was ten i'm
asking you guys what this game oh let me look at it where's
the the board all right i'll look up to i thought we got ten
i got it let me look we got fov harvesters backpack wait so
one two three four five six seven eight nine ten we got ten
i think that's what i came up with too i also have yeah fov
one harvesters two backpack three all right it comp four
charge rifle five nade six survival item seven no
attachments eight alt nine am i missing one oh and the heart
10.
yeah 10 my heart it was the heart guys i put i posted 10 in
our chat uh only one other person so far got 10.
i don't know i feel like somebody's gonna have like 12 or 14
or somebody should realistically yeah like the last game
someone got 14.
so i feel like someone must have got 14 uh 14 or something.
Currently it's a tiebreaker.
I wonder how they did the game one because there was like a
three way tiebreaker or something, right?
I think they did.
I think they just gave it to whoever won the game or was
closest to winning the game.
The closest to winning?
What's our placement?
We got...
Oh, never mind.
Someone got 11.
It doesn't matter.
Someone already got 11.
damn
no what if i just edit 12
i guess new map new map time hopefully the cards like
hopefully a new card tempo says new cards oh it's up oh it's
up it's up i look one red armor oh my god it's easier i love
it knock yourself with a thermite okay we can do the pve for
sure is there a comp do a finisher i'm gonna look there
right now we need a caustic alt knock and we need get a
knock with valk rockets 300 damage with emp and we need
watson crypto the crypto one is kind of easy now crypto
caustic and watson and valk that's the watson one um watson
is draw heart with watson fence we could just play crypto
that just sounds like that's so easy i can do that again and
then there's rave too get the kidnap with portal um red
armor we also have to take the craft cannon three times oh
that's easy died out of bounds and he did that last game
what the 10 revives you could just sit there and spam spam
with somebody wait have take grab spam with opponent wait i
actually need to like collude with somebody wait does this
mean oh you have to win one person can do the grab cannon
thing because it's not three round trip does it not no it
just meant like it means like you go back and forth oh you
do three times yeah times three round trips yeah I'm just
saying you go back and forth three times because that's a
round trip okay what's the comp then we need what the Watson
one is free right yeah okay the crypto one's pretty free too
if we live right 300 damage yeah it's like two EMPs We can
literally just like one person one wait does any does do
they craft do any of them craft does crypto or Watson have
crafting for banners or no we can just play crypto and grab
the banner and drone I was just thinking oh yeah crypto
would right no I'm just thinking if there's crafting we can
just have one person fly literally fly outside map and then
we craft them
I mean, realistically, it's probably just Crypto Watson
Valk, I'd assume.
Crypto Watson Valk.
Yeah, we can do that.
We do Valk for the Oob as well and try to get someone with
the rockets, and then you can just...
Okay, so what are all the ones we can do in POI?
Knock with Therm.
Knock to PvE if we get a good POI.
Clear with melee if we get a good POI.
Don't use a survival item.
The Grav Cannon's doable.
That's just one person to do that.
Yeah, the Watson fence is doable.
doable ten revives doable that's pretty it's pretty azo is
it like full it's it's just knocked and revived right yeah
we literally just like pve that spam crouch with opponent
all right we can do that that's easy um a full inventory of
backpacks or sorry a full inventory of bats blue bag use all
three times wait a full inventory of bat batteries where's
that the bottom who's playing what oh my god that's a lot of
batteries
i can do crypto i suppose i feel like the battery thing is
like almost impossible yeah well we can either play um
actually i don't know i don't think i don't see Where is the
crypto one?
Dude, 300 damage with EMP.
Is that overall or like one EMP?
I think it's overall.
There's no way.
There's no way you can get that in one.
Yeah.
Like that's... I mean, unless you did it at the very end of
the game.
And like... I mean, we could just loot POI, do as many as we
can.
And then we just try to play UAV, Valcult to get an end game
to play the rest of the game what I guess.
Right?
Yeah.
We just have to avoid people.
Because we're playing.
I mean, actually, I don't know.
Hopefully we get a P.O.P.
If we get a P.O.I.
with PvE, we can get two of them automatically.
Yeah.
It's easy.
Do you want a Valk or Crypto?
I can play either, I don't know.
I can't play Valk, so I'll do.
All right, I'll go back.
And I'll draw a heart with my fences.
It's easy.
There's a P20 knock.
It's your favorite, Heemey.
Now you can have attachments to it.
Oh, my God.
I don't have to play on 90 of them.
Yeah.
yeah oh my god i just realized it's a great day my mood is
improved you got so much practice with the p20 girl i had
zero damage last game okay um what practice we didn't buy
i'll probably i'll shoot the spiders with my we're on cedo
cedo station cedo station new p.o.i is crazy there's no pv
there's no pve though and we're center map so oh it's
horrible we might have to we might have to just drop some of
them and just play for like the the end game stuff but we
could do the the grab cannon the grab one's kind of one of
us has to do it though not god not all of us have to be
there we can do the one at our poi we can do the one at our
poi but we gotta be careful three round trips like couldn't
we just take one round trip and that would be three if we
all just took it there and back wouldn't that be so i guess
round trips just each of us it doesn't say sing like single
person i guess it yeah i think does that count at the very
bottom it says use alt three times one person like it
specifies like if it's a one person challenge or a group so
i think we technically could all just yeah take it there and
back once and be done all right yeah we can do that wait the
200 damage with one frag we can just do that with pve can't
we we just group them all the spiders together would that be
200 damage would you damage points on the board oh i don't
know if it means spiders or not i mean we also have to do
pve with melee only so yeah i mean if we get the one melee
off oh is it all pve is melee or yeah clear pve with me so
that has to be all we have to clear it but that's like one
like spider yeah we had to fight with people for the pve but
i could throw one nade at like a prowler and get the bottom
one 200 damage maybe i don't think it would do 200 though i
don't know i don't know i guess we just have to make sure
somebody's hold up somewhere and then just throw a nade yeah
for like a whole team yeah
hmm hey now it's one red army wait we weren't winning though
how did someone got 14 so i mean last game somebody got 14
as well it's the same person they just duping challenges
it's the same person that got last one as well that's crazy
they got for game two
i wonder what they did to like hit all of that so fast they
probably just did the early ones and then had a good game
honestly yeah but two in a row they're so lucky senox why
aren't you as lucky as amu it's just impossible to get lucky
guys we have three more games guys three more it's okay we
don't make it to finals that means we have another chance in
the other two tournaments we're playing the long game here
we're playing a long game do you think it's so worth it if
we get a good zone we just rotate to it probably right and
we just do the ones in the building and play for like the
the damage and stuff we don't want to go to the finals yet
so we can do the other tournaments like the booster one
would take a long time it's the long con it's the long con
just the process i'll make it into the finals on the last
tournament oh that's just one where are my pod clips guys we
should just it wait for the team to take it oh my gosh we're
capping the cannons no i'd be oh no we should finish your
challenge finish your grab challenge and then just cap it
yeah no we should totally do that it's it's the plan and
before the crypto scans us though you know like i feel like
you're gonna throw a crypto drone wait
you guys send a clip you guys send a clip there's one clip
is this what the fuck is this why is it i'm sending this
this is my one clip i'm sending because that's the only clip
i have
i'm gonna write the only clip my chat was will
putting that in there that is the only clip you guys I can't
believe it.
Guys!
We need actual clips!
It's gonna be voted!
Guys, this is going to be voted on!
We need actual clips!
I'm busy editing another one.
Guys, I swear to fucking God.
This is... Oh, shit!
Good!
Okay, here we go.
Wait, I'm gonna look at this clip i'm watching this oh my
god it's the fucking senox clip
all right here you go all right i'm posting that one too
it's okay we're gonna game the system if we have enough no
we can't have too many clips guys we can't guys i know my
clips are off it is if guys okay here's the plan we want
that thousand dollars that having clips off should not stop
us from this maybe we just get a crazy zone if you're
passionate enough it will not stop you there you us guys
this is a team effort everyone team effort crypto can scan
for enemies at least yeah only it's one emp so you're gonna
have to hit like a multiple team emp i think okay i'll try
hopefully we just get if we're in zone you can just wait
it's one emp like he said it was one zero seven it's one emp
and mine said yes oh okay that's like end zone shit right
there you might be able to land on the beacon and hit it
twice for double evo you should be able to actually
depending on the time am i pinging that's weird where is oh
hey sarcedo hey we have we have beacon isn't double you
anymore sorry i didn't mean to oh that's not i'm so sorry
it's fine it's fine it's good i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
loot out here and loot in someone can loot the big building
and then this and someone just get the middle and stuff i'll
get the middle and stuff i'll do here okay are you not
landing on the beacon wait i don't think you can anymore
apparently someone said my show watson can't wait do i land
on the beacon no you're the no just watson no i'm the beacon
oh shit okay guys you should be able to hit it twice so i'll
be here i'll do here then i got confused the scans see this
is why i'm the content creator i don't remember who does
what i'll do one wait can you not do twice we can all have
attachments right i guess not that's what someone said if
i'm believing him oh okay i won't I don't believe him.
I was that we were hitting it twice.
Oh, OK.
Maybe not.
No, no, just wait.
Just wait.
I'm OK.
I don't trust.
I'm the content creator.
I don't know.
We got good zone.
Oh, my God, we did.
I think we might just play zone this game.
I'm not going to lie because we just get in.
We can do all of them for free.
Not me.
Are you hearing some stuff behind me?
We should have said you should know.
You're literally a pro play.
How do you not know?
Well, they they updated it and then they reverted the patch.
i don't know when they fix it oh i'm gonna hit this evo
harvester if i find a thermite i'm just gonna do the
thermite uh i don't think we have extra i know what uh
there's no evo harvester level up thingy there's no no i
didn't see one i just crafted bat and then we're gonna we're
gonna go zone we're gonna that's it we can get a good
spotter play okay oh wait there's an r9 in here Oh, that's a
carbine.
Oh, I thought I found the thermite.
Never mind.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Do I get the revive or the fallen stars?
Uh, honestly, I don't even know.
Uh-huh.
Let's run up on this hill and then I can, I can, uh, Valkal.
Okay.
Oh yeah, we gotta melee these.
Yeah, either we, let's just, let's just play for the
challenges.
Fuck on his own.
Let's go do, let's go melee these spiders and then do we let
someone die to him?
Uh, yeah.
Wait, there's a third bite here.
I'm gonna do...
Oh, I already have a third bite.
You can down your...
Yeah, I'm gonna down myself now.
Let's wait till we get to the building and the spiders.
Make sure we don't get pushed.
Oh, okay.
There's a purple helmet.
Uh, I'll do the pylon.
Oh, wait.
There's...
You can do your heart in this building too, if you'd like.
Yeah, let's get to the building.
There's a care package on us too.
This is really good.
let's uh let's do the pve last you can knock yourself with
the thermite in the building and do the the hearts and then
we can get the care package and do the pve stuff hey I'll do
the hearts wait I'll knock myself first and then do the or
someone else knock themselves doesn't matter whoever
whoever's just drop your armor knock yourself yeah I'm just
gonna try doing the hearts now okay
all right we got the res yeah thank you this is not a heart
okay okay let's do the let's let's do the melee pve and then
one person oh actually that's a heart right the melee pve
and then one person should die to the spot oh come on that
is such a heart there you go that has to be a heart that's
like half a heart okay wait no like if you think yes it is
you look at like this direction yes that's a heart i'm not
getting heart from this at all come uh come punch these out
somebody help me punch these out okay okay okay that's a
heart i'll i can redo it another time no no you work on that
i'm gonna go melee okay okay okay you keep an eye and make
sure nobody walks up over doing this yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna let them kill me too let them get me low let this one
I'll let it kill me.
I'm looking around right now and I'm also making my heart.
I need to go aggro these spiders.
Can they aim bot me?
Oh my god, they're just missing.
This is staying forever.
Wait, I thought you were- Just make sure we don't get walked
up on.
I'm trying to make sure right now while I make this heart.
Yeah, kill the rest and then answer resume.
Okay, there you go, heart.
Alright.
Just make sure nobody pulls up on us.
We can punch up for us.
Can I get a mic it?
Yeah, here.
I don't have one I had to use.
I dropped a headshot.
Okay.
Yeah, we did it.
Let's go.
Can we do the grab cannon here maybe?
Yeah, yeah.
Look at this.
Heart, heart, heart, heart.
Look at it.
That's good.
Definitely a heart.
Yeah, there we go.
Perfect.
So, do we figure out how much we have to do this actually?
Or do we all just take it twice?
We all take it back and forth once.
We all take it there and back.
There and back once.
Yeah.
And let me take it first just in case there's somebody
there.
okay we're good you can take it we did it we can grab the
eva harvester and then we're gonna on platform on the
platform of um okay take it back take back yep and then we
done we can take it we can take it later we can take it
later we're done we're done we're done with this we did it
can you uh hit this UAV with your with your drone there's a
team over here so we's I'm grabbing this eva harvester all
right there's a team above on the rock by the way god rock
just just let's just UAV with drum and then we're gonna play
in a barometer they're hitting UAV right now if they push us
we have to go back to the building and hold it and fight
them hey
how do I hit this shit you're just you're pissing on it nice
how do I hit this shit that's not right e there we go let's
go back to the building damn I hit him for 153 we're gonna
we're gonna go to get up here okay we're gonna take out from
them i'm 500 away from getting the red evo on a lot of
people are like uh out of bad i guess because they'll not
get a map i honestly think we could just go get into zone
and have a good game no it's like nobody in zone yeah let's
play for uh top barometer and hit the uav up there and then
we'll walk up on the zone all right there is a barometer
team so we might have to walk into it yeah we're gonna walk
up up here look i have like two four six i have six bats do
you guys have a lot of bats on you i know one they're rising
right now come come come come hey i'm right behind i'm here
Oh, they did the auto bounce shit.
Pop your evac on the roof.
Are we going to use our survival item?
Oh, yeah, true.
Don't use that one of them.
Is that one of them?
Yeah, don't use any.
You might as well just drop them just because.
That's a survival item.
I don't see it on this card.
Oh, it is.
There it is.
Sorry, I'm stupid.
I'm stupid.
I'm sorry.
There might be a team riding inside of here.
Just be careful, okay?
We're going in or not.
Oh, there's a team over there.
No team.
Okay, can you hit the UAV in barometer, which run again?
Yep.
Is there any way we can die to Uber on here?
I don't know if we're gonna be able to do that actually,
because we'd have to use our Moby to res.
I mean, you have the crypto drone to just fly to mobile res.
Yeah, but there aren't many in the zone.
There's one.
Let's hit the beacon.
We might be able to just get a good spot in zone, so.
I'm watching it.
Yeah.
let's just go play up here let's go let's go
there is someone up on the hill so crouch spam if they are
we can get the crouch yeah we gotta get the crouch
we're probably gonna go to the left I just want to see if
there's anybody up here actually they're on the on my scan
no yeah but I think they're third-party news they're in the
opener here well let me shoot or let them walk can we shoot
no let's just go to the corner just go to the corner whoa
careful
good let's go quick we can stay here with you oh somebody
and then do we have a lot of nades we could do the down 10
times thing in the corner um i only have two i have two
nades on me we have how many reses we have one res only
right we have two we have two i did as well we died to
I don't see him.
Oh.
You can get a jet down and we're going to play this whole
corner area.
Okay, I'll put a jet here.
And then just get fences up on our back.
Careful.
There's water here.
Whoa.
You can come back here.
You're full safe back here.
No, my jet.
He's in the tower.
Just crouch.
I'm literally being grieved from everywhere.
Jesus.
I'm batting in her hair.
Well.
revive number three.
Let's hope they're res- I hear a bloodhound ult.
I hear blood on ult.
Okay.
They're walking up.
They're walking up, yeah.
One inch from the bloodhound behind the rock.
I can't see them right now.
I'm healing up.
You're full safe behind the trees back here.
Okay.
From there from the tower.
I'm just fencing up for us.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
We could just keep getting knocked to that tower, Sam.
For the knocks.
Yeah, but that gives them Yeah.
You can play back here.
Play back on me.
I'll wait for my ult and then we can put ult here.
Depending on next zone, we might just valkal and go by the
spot.
We're just kind of waiting for zone to pull.
Does anyone have a med kit or a white house?
I can give you two syringes.
That's it though.
Thanks.
Is there anyone you can look for?
I know we need two teams to do the MP thing, huh?
Yeah, we do.
Oh, there's a new team across from us?
Yeah.
That's really awesome.
You can sit just sit behind these right now for now.
Whoa, okay, I'm gonna just sit behind That should be okay
I'm okay No, my baby, I got the red armor one Nice, we got
red armor.
Nice I have well, let's play back on me so Sorry, I'm slowly
re-getting my shit.
I'm trying to think if we could just walk up into a spot,
but Gosh this team It's annoying.
It's one team holding all of Coastal doing that.
Bro, I only have one shield cell left.
I can give you some.
Yeah, I'm using my last cells right now.
Yeah, you just give it to him, I'm good.
I can regen my shields.
I'm gonna drop a couple and I'm gonna go push this guy off
of us.
We're just chilling.
This is our home for now.
Are they fighting down the hill?
We might third party down the hill if they fight.
Because there's a team up here.
They're gonna come shoot us in the back.
are there anything else we try and get some eyes on this i
don't really there's not much to live by we live in the
bamboos there's a team down here so we gotta be careful if
you can see if there's two teams playing on each other you
can emp them for the thing i know i was trying to look is
there a team walking up the hill from my self 207 one team
full team here
i have uh should i save my watson gen or uh use it now uh
honestly i'm not sure this i think you wait a little bit but
we have to play like just loose for now until people landing
on us flying over us we can look to kill them maybe they're
gonna land it in between a team i'm gonna hit the i'm gonna
hit a big niger might be the 200 i'm gonna try to break down
right now jen's broken jen's broken i'm right side i'm being
shot too yeah yeah this team i have no heels guys i'm
literally gonna get knocked i'm looking at my right side i'm
looking at our right at the moment you have no what wait oh
i might be dead to this too i have to use yeah i'm dead to
this i got shot from a team to the right here they might
push oh no no they got they got the ulted they got ulted oh
okay goodbye i mean i was safe but i can come back i'm gonna
All right, Sena.
They're running off the hill.
You're dead.
What do you mean?
There's a team coming up the hill right here.
You could have gotten this res.
You could have easily res this.
What other challenges?
Are there any other challenges that we can get?
We've got red armor.
We got knock.
One, two, three.
me look.
Let me look since I'm fucking dead.
Have you knocked anyone with your bow rockets?
You could go for that.
I'll try to do that this time.
Go for that.
You could go for a finisher.
A 360 no scope with a sniper.
There's a sniper, a finisher.
I could craft you in Reza.
Should I try to Reza you guys in here for fun?
It counts as two Reza's now.
Yeah.
But is that wouldn't it?
Sure.
There might be a team still there, but sure.
There's so many teams back here.
I don't know how you can get there.
I am going to say.
If you can get a big ass nade, like a frag nade, 200 damage.
I would just try for those two.
I'm going to go for the Valkyro kids.
You've used your ult three times, right?
Have we?
Ooh.
Um, I think you used it two times, not three.
Yeah, I'm going to use it one more.
I don't live.
Oh, there they come.
Okay, what else?
I think that's it.
Unless you see a Trident driving by.
What was the Trident for?
Stick him with an Arc Star.
Wait, crouch spamming!
You can crouch spam and hope they crouch spam back before
they kill you.
Since you are a rat, that would be funny.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Before...
Maybe I just run up on him and crouch spam.
Okay, but like not now.
No, that's who you are.
Yeah, do it for you.
It's okay.
If they AD spam you, that's a crouch spam.
That counts
Oh shit That's one You're so fucked Would they push you in
front of you
Okay I mute myself Because I don't want it to distract him
Because he's like super focused right now Someone come
cranks around with me This would have been amazing to play
as Watson right here Ugh No, it counts because they're
dodging your bullets by crouch spamming, so it counts, sort
of.
I'm just going to crouch spam for the rest of the game and
pray that someone kills me as crouching.
Make sure you get your Valkyrie knock first.
With your Q.
Yeah.
There's a full team right behind you.
Yeah, I hear them right over here.
It's okay.
Maybe they'll be crouched, too.
Find another rat.
Oh, you're in the middle of the zone.
That is not good.
I might just Valco when I get it and for 2% and just get the
point.
We need one more, right?
I've used it twice.
Yeah, you need white.
Yeah, you only use it twice.
You didn't use it the third time.
You might as well pair marry this.
You don't know.
Wait, but where would you go?
Oh, there is.
I'm dead.
There's nowhere to go.
You can't go anywhere.
At least you can see where everybody is.
Wait, land on top of the silo.
Could be safe.
Well, now you can't land on top.
Crash spam.
Go crash spam.
Maybe they'll be good to you.
Look, if they crouch once, that's considered a crouch spam.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
Just live there.
Jesus Christ how many teams are there that's a lot oh no no
time you tried shit didn't even give you the chance you
should have spammed harder it was so close how many do we
have let's see I'm not sure this one seems a lot harder to
two three four uh i think we have six six seven seven i
think we only have seven get melee knock because the melee
not consider would pv i don't think i don't think i think
the melee knock has to be on a player.
Oh, seven.
We have seven.
Five, six.
Seven.
Wait, what are the eight?
We have eight.
One, two.
Eight.
Yeah.
We have eight.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't think that's a winner.
There's no way.
I feel like more teams got eight.
The highest in there is eight so far.
Yeah, but there's still teams alive.
I'm pretty sure teams alive are the ones that are going to
have the most.
maybe maybe we go back in the VOD and I was crouch spamming
and someone else across the map is crouch spamming pretty
sure you know you know I'm pretty sure that happened you
know when you were wingmanning that one team that was under
the bridge they were crouch spamming they were crouch
spamming they were try to dodge your bullets that's a nine
we're not gonna win but it's like the message we had done
earlier there's the get knocked 10 time that one the 10
revival and so well i feel like the out of bounds one we
could have done yeah sure the out of bounds one yeah 10
revives and out of bounds ones we could do and the crush of
the opponent i put us as nine because i counted the crush
we're not gonna win anyways just the message overall I
mean we could easily do the revive outside of zone yeah we
like hug zone and just keep rising yeah yeah we could have
done that thing or like just be at the edge of zone and then
just revive like we do this not revive not revive at the
edge of zone red armor is doable thermite doable BVE is
doable no survival items doable grab canna doable yeah we
just in this next game we need to do the die dot die to
bounce and rabbit or redstone time so we have to sit in zone
and hill yeah i think we get bad if we have a bad poi and a
bad like uh zone we can do that yeah just do edge i should
be easy or do we keep the valk or the crypto like we're
gonna the crypto was like mid but yeah i don't think we play
for the crypto EMP it's kind of high so i'm not gonna lie
yeah that's too hard to do um what else could help you guys
we do we're doing watson for the fence we could play
let's see because the fence was super easy i mean we could
do ray the portal or costa cults or costic i think costic is
nice uh either one i think costic is good for his own
control yeah with that plus watson we'd be like locked down
yeah people can't push us as easily i'm done okay uh do we
do valk just to get in the zone because we're gonna be
sitting in zone dying 10 times yeah we do valk caustic we
can play so we can we can craft brenner and rise and oob
without having to use a moby yeah like a conduit or loba
well what to get rid of one oh lifeline could help with the
revives we can't get rid of watson because we need watson
for the thing we could play lifeline for the red armor if
you want instead of caustic because it gives
anyway zero got 14 so yeah we were never gonna get close we
were second technically if they don't have another nine yeah
zero's team got 14.
i'm pretty sure they were like end game or something
damn if we were game three with second we could have
advanced to the finals
let's see what else is there do the battery one if we play
edge oh lifeline's good for the battery one actually because
you don't you get a ton of bats from the pack oh yeah i'll
do lifeline yeah yeah so you're doing my lifeline watson
what's the third val for the rotation yeah and then you have
the rockets
oh yeah this this tournament is pretty difficult these
challenges are hard i i think the hardest part chat right
now is just remembering the like I'm just like what's in the
challenges again it's so difficult to remember I'm just
listening to what they tell me to do because I'm like I
don't know I don't even know what the challenges are I'm
just like okay I'm just I'll just exist oh wait nice okay
this is a good clip good good guys thank you guys for
clipping it if we can't win If we can't win the fucking, the
tournament itself, we will win the Clips Challenge.
We will win the Clips Challenge instead.
I put the goodbye you're dead.
I put that chick clip in.
We gotta get this W somewhere.
I believe I got left for dead.
Wait, Tempo's running scrims at the same time as this
tournament?
No, what?
He has seven monitors.
I just realized he's running the fucking Apex Pro scrims the
same time as this fucking tournament.
I saw him posted, like, here are the scores from today's
scrims.
I was like, wait a minute, there's a tournament going on.
What you mean here are the scores with today's scrims oh my
god don't wonder for those who don't know tempo runs the pro
pro team scrims in apex legends so not only is he running
this tournament but he's also running the scrims at the same
time so it makes sense why he has seven monitors he is
definitely multitasking right now he is we just need to
stack white mats then when we're looting Because we're
probably going to have to go sit in the zone for the whole
game to be able to get all.
Because if we sit in the zone, we get the out of bounds as
well.
We get the revives.
We get the extra bats.
And then that's just an extra three from what we had this
last game.
Yeah.
We have crafting right, right?
So we can literally, one of us can fly out of bounds.
Yeah, you can just die instantly.
We can craft.
Yeah, so we can get that point instantly.
Yeah, and we just play for support bins for the bats.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, my God, guys.
I just...
I just realized he added the melee remember when I told him
add a knockout with punch he actually added it we
contributed to the tournament look where is it get a melee
knock we contributed to the to the card I actually wrote
that to him we did it if we don't win anything at least we
had something on the card we helped guys all of us helped
together this is a group effort of contribution right there
nice achievement i can we get an edge i've contributed to
the tournament
wait what's our what's our our pli oh they're doing it right
now okay okay the And I can't believe this team got 13 We
would have we would have been oh we would have been like uh
We're second is zero one before
I don't believe it we were so close.
We were so close We're doing our part guys.
We have so many clips guys.
We're fucking Drowning clips right now Everybody said one
but I have three
I'm deleting the meow one.
I'm deleting it.
I'm deleting that.
This is not going to be on our record.
Because now we have more clips.
I'm going to delete the cat one.
That's not professional.
That is not professional.
Chad.
No, we're not keeping it.
Nobody's going to vote for it.
Guys, the votes are happening in...
Girl's Discord.
You're not in her Discord.
Her fans are going to be so confused.
Because the vote.
I don't rate her Discord, by the way.
I do not rate her Discord.
It has no gameplay.
No.
Guys, we're not rigging the vote.
We're not rigging the vote.
We have to give good content.
Oh man.
We got Jurassic.
We're center met.
We have to have good content.
Wait, but that's good for PvE though, isn't it?
There's no PvE there anymore.
Oh, wait, no.
There's no prouder's in the middle.
No, what's the point?
It's here, we have the cannons.
We have the cannons.
I think we're going to just have to loot the POI and thread
the needle and make it like a PvE and just avoid Zim's.
and like work our way out of zone if we want to do the the
the challenges let me see
all right don't worry it's fine we'll be fine i believe in
this maybe like the zone is like so far from us maybe so
it'll be fine oh my gosh i can't believe i can't believe
they've removed the I can't believe they removed the fucking
this is why I'm the content creator exactly this is exactly
why I am the content creator I didn't even remember where
the fuck the what I didn't even remember the new map does
not have PVE anymore I am the content creator of this team
it is fine respect we're not putting yabba it's not gonna
win us anything not gonna win us anything the only reason
you wanted there is because you wanted to show on girl
stream and that is why I'm exactly taking it out this is
exactly why I took out that clip because I'm not having that
clip show up on stream okay okay if if I put that clip back
if I put that clip back and we don't win you guys owe me
somewhere i will get that thousand dollars
i will get that somewhere
okay all right yeah all right all right i'll put it back in
i'll put it back in
okay where the fuck is it you guys delete it oh no no it's
this it's still there i just went by slight change in two of
the challenges okay here we go oh slight change because it
caused too much revives oh there's no more revives win a
game with less than 1500 damage which are the one day
changing get a knock with a mozambique win a game less than
15 okay that's so fucking specific have to be in zone all
game that's actually better for Jurassic I guess all right
let's see okay I'm putting back the clip guys I'm putting it
back guys just for you guys I'm putting you need that easy
that's actually big for us a huge for us okay okay guys I
don't know if you guys notice but it says win the game oh
wait a minute yeah I'm just saying I'm just let me calm down
then yeah yeah i got i don't the closest we got was when
senox got us both killed and got it for it it's okay this
like at least like you know we can get the bozab i think
i think that'll work yeah i don't know this is gonna be
weird we have to pray there's pve we can get to wait who's
gonna do the mozam then uh whoever gets one okay whoever
whoever gets the mozam does the mozam i think like no one's
ever gonna fucking drive the trident they're shaking unless
you're like collude with a team and was like hey can you get
on it we can exchange tridents i mean same with the crouch
spamming like it was hard they just instantly killed you go
to crouch spam on someone they just But some of them crouch
spam to dodge bullets.
So you both crouch spam to dodge bullets.
It's considered crouch spamming.
There's that.
I hate being social.
I will be an introvert forever.
fuck i smelled i spilled my bubble tea i was trying to peel
this is like me for real no i squeezed too much air no i did
it again fuck okay okay let me wipe this off real fast i
have a little i have ah i'm a mess i'm dropping everything
i'm a mess right now okay not my bubble tea being an
extrovert is not worth it it's not let me just fix this real
fast fix this all right at least i could stay as locked in
here I have to worry about...
This is game two.
Swapping.
Yeah, there's two more games.
There's one and one other.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna go this time.
Make sure.
I'm already on Watson.
I don't have to worry.
Yeah.
Don't have to worry.
Alright, let me make sure I unmute myself.
Alright.
Here we go.
And we got Beacon.
I guess they're...
There might be a universe where we just go to zone because
there's no resin ones anymore.
Wait, are we not going to fly off the map?
They got rid of it.
Oh, they got rid of it.
Oh, no.
There's no UB one either, right?
Yeah, no, they're gone.
No UB or you guys.
I'm just going to line close and line close.
Somebody do the...
I'll go over here.
I'll go do this.
One person loot this and then beacon and bunker and stuff.
I'll go right side.
I'll land in the back and look my way.
I'm gonna go to the tunnel.
I'm gonna do the tunnel.
Oh, I have a thermite.
I can do it right now.
The thermite.
But oh wait, and actually no, I have to wait for you guys.
I'll come revive you.
Yeah, give me a second.
Yeah, no, it's fine.
I'll just wait until you're closer and then I'll do the
thermite.
Cool, cool, cool.
I got one of the nades.
Not nades, bats we need.
Same.
That's, um...
Alright.
scanning
scanning now
all right i'm gonna run i'm just gonna run a repeater well
let me know when you're done uh downloading you can just
come come into the the tunnel when you're done should we
take the we can try to do right out here i'm gonna grab it
you can do the the the booster on you really quick if you
want yeah i was gonna say we can do the cannon i'm gonna you
got you guys i'm gonna grab this eva really quick so we lose
all right okay i'm gonna do the third light right now and
then you can give me the the the the suck all right i'm
doing it oh i got the crunch down with this guy did you
should i be a bastard no do it do it who cares oh i might
die whoa whoa whoa whoa okay what happened she just did her
Yeah, I'm...
Oh, oh, I thought there was a team on us.
Yeah, no, no, I was doing my thermite.
Okay.
All right, I need the suck now.
Have you done the booster yet?
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know.
We shouldn't do this one.
The pylon team is going to kill us.
Let's go up here.
What is the booster one exactly?
Oh, here's a Mozamb.
We just hit the...
We have to hit the grab cannon.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just...
I'm not in the senti if anyone wants to get a no scope knock
with it.
I'm doing the Mozamb right now.
Let's go.
Let's go up here.
Okay.
We might be able to do this grab cannon.
I'm not sure.
It's kind of risky.
It's sent him out.
It's an airdrop over here.
We should play for this.
There was a team over here, so we might have to fight for
it.
Oh, man.
Maybe they won't have blue armor.
Maybe they're still white armor.
Are we not going to do the cannon?
I want to get the package because we can get red off of it.
Oh, okay.
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna hold right here someone there's a
team out here just play these rocks in like someone watch
behind us and somebody's watching back i'll watch their
backs you should uh you should grab the evo on lifeline all
right okay they took that out and then you can take your
your care packaging we can get double care package yeah i'm
on 80 okay you will i get it when i get this uh if there's
an evo cache in it okay just do with the luck i'm grabbing
the your purple your purple gun or the the care package gun
one and we can get another you can get right yeah yeah yeah
yeah take the purple one and then you can the the upgrade
that gives you the care package oh lifeline upgrade oh sorry
i was like wait what are you talking about i looked in the
care package i only have this i have gift next all is a play
drop or gain self-revive the that one the first one the
first one i'm gonna take it and scout it make sure there's
somebody there we'll be able to do this one okay oh wait oh
my heart I don't see anybody.
All right, do I take it?
I'm going to take it.
Yeah, just give me a take it back.
And then you have to take it too.
Yeah, I already took it the one time.
I just stopped out for it.
All right, I've done my double.
So it's up to...
Actually, just take it back and come back to it.
I'm not even going to take it.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
I can just take it and then it'll be six.
Okay, that's six.
And then let's go for the PvE up here.
The PvE one's up here.
I need to drop my ult.
I might die.
You might have to take it back.
shooting at you shooting at you take it back take it back
take it back we craft them we craft them later just go craft
me go craft me go craft me there is a crafter not close to
us at all um you can play for cascade just play slow and
play for cascade uh i'll go back to cascade then all right
yeah just play cascade just play slow that's unlucky i'm
just gonna run a cascade first and if i die you don't go to
cascade all right just one of us stick together I feel like
it best if I just scout ahead because then you can just res
both of us if I die Yeah, that's much more easier.
So I'll just go up first
Because like at least for that you can get your red I feel
like you're gonna push though You can you rise on the we
might we might rise on the the spider choke The spider one
because we can do the spiders after they're not gonna go
craft and you head to the spider Got you you go ahead you go
to spider first I think there's a team there.
There's a team near me.
So I'll just grab you now.
You might have to get me on the waterfall, yeah, and we go.
No, I'm just going to grab you now.
So if I die, you might as well just craft.
Like I'm going to go the other way.
Maybe the one on your right.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a fight to my love.
I'm just going to go straight to the...
Don't go to the...
Don't go to the smudger truck.
Go to Doki.
Sorry.
Tell who you were speaking to.
No, that's okay.
All right, here I go.
though by this probably gonna get pushed on us you can
resume just run away if you want yeah i'm just gonna run
also i don't want he need to be close to me then i think he
just hurt somebody no okay we could do the spiders in front
of us yeah i'm gonna look command center when i rise in if
there's nobody up there you just both run up there are they
here you should be good to go command center i don't see
anybody yet i'm gonna go i'm gonna uh shoot
We gotta let one of them knock us too.
Knock one.
They could still be up there, so we can't find him.
Yeah, I'm just gonna do one first.
I'm just gonna do one.
I'm just bad at melee.
What the fuck?
Just the last one.
You punching them, yeah?
Yeah, I'm punching them.
I'm just doing one at a time and then just let it knock
somebody.
Yeah, I'm just doing one at a time because I don't want to
risk it.
You know, wait for me.
point all right i'm just gonna heal up there's the last one
there's one more i'll do it let it let it kill me i'm lost
yeah you're on there it doesn't take forever just make sure
nobody pulls up while we're doing this look up i'm looking
top someone look bottom looking down i hear a car go shoot
them shoot that car back on the one i'll try i'll try where
is it where up the hill oh that way okay bro can these
spiders shoot me they're not behind something so they are
growing me i'm hiding these spiders are like brain dead just
instantly lifeline knows me and punched them up yeah i know
i just couldn't stay close because i'm looking at top still
they're literally just missing on me that's so unfortunate
oh team below team below oh no really can you Can you shoot
them?
Can you shoot them?
The team below.
Are they walking up?
I can't tell.
We're good.
I'm gonna risk it.
Let this one come here.
Please kill me.
Please.
Just shoot down the hill.
Shoot down here.
Res me.
Res.
Yeah, I threw a drone already.
We have to run.
They're gonna push us.
I don't have a fucking shot.
We have all.
We cleared our spiders.
We cleared it.
Okay, let's run.
Let's run.
Get up top.
Come on.
I threw a drone already.
I was like, totally prepared to.
I just want to die to them.
kit for you yeah i'll grab it when we get up here wait did
you call the package oh you did already right i did yeah
okay can i get the the phoenix okay here you go i'm just
gonna watch behind us and really quick i'm a lot looking
front yeah they're not coming yeah we'll make sure there's
nobody in front of us though i'm gonna i'm gonna just lay
here for us in here footsteps on my right left left left on
me come back if you have to okay we're just gonna wait here
till zone close All right, I'm looking at the door.
I need a scrap loot because I don't have anything because I
died.
I can give you meds here.
Here's chill.
I can give you syringes though, the best I can.
I'm gonna scan.
I can give you syringes.
I'm okay, I have some.
Can we hit beacon?
Yeah, we can.
I need a sentinel.
Holy fuck.
Circle as far.
Mmm.
Okay.
I'm coming this way.
I might zip up and see if there's anybody up there.
Wait.
Wait, there's a sniper here.
Did you grab the sniper?
Yeah, you did.
Okay.
Uh, yeah.
I'm just looking for a Sentinel.
Yeah, there might be a team riding on top.
If there is, then I'm gonna have to, I'm gonna drop.
I will not be surprised.
I can put, like, fences at the bottom, too.
Yeah, put a bunch of fences up, and then if I drop, just
lifeline res.
They're gonna drop, so you have to get ready to instacel
them once you lifeline res, man.
Yeah.
Wait, I have to make a hard still.
Fuck.
Yeah, you can do that.
Yeah, you need to.
All right.
The moment you come, there's nobody above, right?
I don't know yet.
I'm just waiting.
Are you still?
Oh, my God.
You're still...
Wait, can we hit the beacon again?
Um, I can...
Yeah, I can.
They're here, but they're out here.
Okay, I can try.
Okay, I'm just worried.
We don't have to.
Yeah, if you don't want to.
I just want to wait until all of us are together.
You can come up here.
Okay, I'm going to make the heart.
I'm going to make the heart.
I'm coming up.
Can you do it up here?
on the door we're gonna just velcult out of the out of the
top of command okay i'm gonna make the heart guys give me a
sec go for it they're on the door they could be riding
inside so just be careful i don't think they are though i
need to wait i don't have enough seconds i up back quick i
fucked up with my offenses careful they were on the door
and then I can make my heart.
We need to make sure they don't come from over here.
How many bats do we have?
Do we have enough to do the bad thing?
Nope, I have one.
I only have two.
Come over here.
I'm going to see if they're up there or not.
They might have left.
Coming back.
I made my heart.
No, they're still all the way back there.
Well, it's flying.
Is that a third or?
No, it's the same thing.
We're going to Valkalt out of the top.
We just have to slam a spot and pray that it's They're
afraid that it's open.
I'm praying for you.
Here?
Whoa.
This is spooky.
There's definitely a team here.
I saw some shots.
Look for anything open.
Shots from here.
There's a team there.
There's a team here.
There's a team everywhere.
We're slamming the back of this.
We have to instantly get a gen down, okay?
They're going to push us.
Instantly get a gen down if you can.
Got gen?
Nice.
Just hold.
I got it bad.
I got it.
Papa, alt-xel, if you have one.
No, I don't.
Good drain.
I'm trying to...
Stabilize.
Trying not to take damage.
The Kossi-Golf, they play the back.
Yeah.
How is this hitting us?
Oh, my gosh.
Do you have drone?
Can you drone right here?
I just threw it.
I threw it already.
Okay.
It's okay.
Nice.
Just wait for the Kossi- How is that still?
It's fine.
So confused.
We're good.
There you go.
This is very scuffed, but like, it's something.
Do you have any alt-xels?
Yeah.
I'm going to redo the fences now.
Pop, yeah.
Pop that alt-xel for, uh, for Watson John.
Careful.
He's like hard.
I know.
I'm trying to redo this.
Our fences.
Yeah.
No!
what other what other challenges we have to do or can we do
mozan knock win a game with less damage a finisher melee
knock 360 okay so we should just play to win the game at
this point we should just play to win the game at this point
we need the melee finisher 360 i am mosaic longbow i have
the goat loadout right now they're throwing bows up on us
you have watson dren you can pop this you can get watson
dren if you want are you close to red armor i'm 44 right now
to do i should get it how much you offer red armor 224 you
should you should try to poke a little bit and try to get it
because it's a free point if we get it yeah just be careful
all right maybe we just have to wait I think we might just
have to wait I'm really okay I'm gonna pop my alt Excel now
I don't think we can get it in time oh my god you got this I
believe in you you're not 90 fob anymore there's a body out
here.
I'm going to try to loot this body.
There's a Mozambique on it.
This is this is a, this is an area.
I can connect here.
Nice.
There you go.
It looks great.
I'll take this away and then connect you here.
And then...
Does anyone have another gun I can have?
What's your other gun?
You have a vault in 3030.
Wingman L-Star.
You can have the wingman.
Here.
Yeah, I'm longbow Mozambique.
I don't have shit.
I'll take the Mozambique.
Okay.
Don't we need the longbow for a knock?
No, we need senti.
Oh, we need senti.
Go back that on us, on us.
Just play in the corner.
They'll die.
Don't overpeak.
Don't worry.
I'm safe.
We need to get a finish on that.
Oh, he me.
Get careful.
I'm...
Oh, that's mine.
You're fine.
Oh, we're fine.
I am fine in this little corner.
i'm batting okay save on me yeah i'm safe too i'm gonna then
we can't get a finish on that nope no we can't i don't think
we should try i don't know yeah you have a third lifeline
pack you call it 83 83 83 you these guys behind us oh
they're gonna fucking all soon we are definitely not in zone
yeah this is gonna be i know i have evac towers a lot but we
shouldn't We can't use it.
We shouldn't use it.
They're directly underneath me.
I might try to go for a Mozam knock on them.
They're right down here.
This is Jent.
I'll stay here and keep the fort down.
I got it.
Nice.
He's on the knock?
We'll keep the fort down.
Yeah, we play for how long on your package?
99.
It's up.
Where do you want it?
Just call it out right here for the...
Yeah, just for the door and block.
Oh, door?
Oh, shit.
No, it doesn't matter.
We're just calling it to call it.
right there is literally nothing in um our best bet is to
get a hell mary uh watson uh we either valkald and pray we
get it off or we run in and wait do we need three ults for
one person how many else do we got it we already called in
three lifeline packs okay three lifeline packs yay
come to me come to me we're just gonna try to rip a valkald
we're gonna die if we walk in no matter what right right
right the valkald thing okay i'll just throw it out in the
box Watson, the moment I got down.
I just don't really know where to go.
Holy fuck.
Oh, this is a little spooky.
We're just going to land late and try to third party
something.
We just got to float.
Yeah.
Maybe go in this corner, go in this corner, go in this
corner.
Right.
Very back, very back corner.
We're hard safe back here.
Okay.
But you're not really.
We have to shoot the guy on the roof.
Target the guy on the roof.
I'm just going to need, need, need.
This is the best I can do.
we just have the hard shoot roof no matter what yeah i'm
just uh put my agenda i'm looking at the roof right now i'm
farming them on the roof oh yeah yeah i'll cover i'll cover
crack them on the roof i knocked one knocked one nice nice
i'm gonna i'm gonna play to kill it just say i got red i'll
go out nice Nice.
That's your one.
Nice.
I don't have...
Knock another one.
Nice.
My drone's up in...
Nine seconds.
It's just one more.
Climb up to me and shoot out the knockdown shields.
There's one person behind knockdowns.
I can help.
You shoot out the knockdowns.
Shoot out the knockdowns.
This is a C3.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
There's one team inside.
One team inside.
We play on the high ground the entire game.
On beacon, on beacon, on beacon.
Free shots, free shots.
It's a flash.
have i don't have uh cover uh all right we just we just play
the high ground and then we just play to kill people on
inside i'm gonna shield cell okay yeah do we are we gonna be
able to get another gem uh no 36 i don't have all the excel
for this actually good i have a head glitch here focus the
door oh my god they're getting farmed i'm gonna look for a
spot right here yeah yeah we're gonna play up here as long
as we can and then we might have to slide on and play their
left their left hide okay i cost her team left i'm looking
i'm looking at the story yeah yeah stay right we just stay
up here as long as we can on beacon on beacon oh then i'll
see i don't see it could be free it's a draw it's a draw
i've been made it's fine i have i don't have bats anymore
i'm gonna shield some i need to do slow slow heals i'm gonna
kill him with valkyrie yeah he should you have to help him i
have to shield slow heal right now that's fine
at the solo in this pill a full three man on the right full
three mount on the left yeah they oh they're they oh they
didn't get running out right shoot the three man i'm
shooting i'm shooting flash flash flash flash flash flash
flash she swapped she's swapped i have no ammo flash flash
we're burning burning burning burning heartburn come to me
come to me come to me come to me come to me come to me come
to me shoot these guys across headshot flash 50 flash knock
them knock them that's down on both teams downs on both
teams Do you have nades, nades, nades, full kill?
No nades, no nades.
Got knocked.
Two, two, one left, one left on this.
There's only one guy on the scene left.
Shoot it out.
They're right below, they're right below.
Are they resing below us?
Don't let them res below us.
I'm trying to make sure.
The scene's going, they're resing below us.
Try to shoot down anything you can.
I'm going.
Full kill, full kill.
One team under, one team under.
Right below, right below.
It's a duo, it's a duo, it's a duo.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
Knocked one, knock one, knock one!
Last kill.
Flash!
Melee, melee, melee!
Oh, just kill him, just kill him, just kill him.
Oh god, no, no!
Fine, fine, fine, fine, fine!
Oh, he's full.
Play knockdown, play knockdown.
He's just sitting behind knockdown, now.
I
wanted to get the melee!
I had no more bullets!
Yeah, I ran out of ammo too.
I ran out of ammo too!
I know, well, fuck.
I know ammo.
I know ammo there.
I honestly didn't know they got that Watson out.
I had two.
I didn't know either.
When you killed that person, I was like, wait, why is that
not game over?
I ran out of ammo.
I had to admit it.
I had no ammo.
We all had nothing.
I used the last four bullets of a longbow and hipfire.
It's not like it was bad.
That is so close.
Maybe we got enough knocks overall.
We didn't see your damage.
We had way more than 1500.
Oh, we had 10 kills because we got the kills.
That's so close.
and we got seven or more kills oh hey nice wait we actually
got a lot hold on let's count let's go let's go okay we got
red armor one two we died of pve 3 we played her with melee
four yep uh no finner more kills five don't use this revival
item six yeah seven grab cannon seven watson eight did you
did you 360 with your nose ghost no nine spam crouch 10
seven or more kills 11 all three 12 we got 12.
we had 12.
oh i think someone got 14.
i think someone got 14.
oh come on if i got that melee would have been 13.
it was so unlucky no no no we have 12.
wait we got 12.
i'm pretty sure someone i'm gonna wait until someone i don't
see anything team six also got 12.
that was got we didn't do batteries we didn't do the mozam
you can't yeah i did i did did anyone had a big nade or what
no no no melee knocks i'm gonna use the bathroom oh my gosh
we were doing so well there uh i mean the only other one we
could have got that game would have been mailing for the
last kill for the last kill which would i mean we tried we
literally all had no ammo so i know i should just fucking
punched like i ran out of wingman i was only mozambique for
the game and i just ran out
Oh, we play that so well, though.
Great job.
People are tallying up, and I don't see anyone with 12.
The winning team only had four.
Wow, that was, that was a pass, dude.
That was a huge.
I should have just threw and we would have won.
Wait, Lifeline's OP.
Dude, I know the fast res.
Oh, like I might, yeah, I'm definitely going to play her
again just because that was huge.
I mean, unless you think we have a better chance.
I think we play the same comp.
Do we do it?
It's pretty good.
The only one we missed was the cost of gold.
Just meleeing people and stuff.
And like a sentinel kill.
But for the most part, we got almost every.
Well, winning that game wouldn't have given us any more
points unless it was.
Yeah, it was just giving us like money and the, yeah.
That's so close.
But so far we have the most.
So far.
Guys, they should give us some pity points.
there i know we've come second for we come second so much oh
my god if i had the ammo i could have killed her it was so
close guys please i want to type out gift 10 gift the subs
you let us have this give us 0.5 One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve.
There's like eight more teams that have not, uh, have not
put their score in.
It can't, it can't still be counting.
Oh, okay.
Seven.
Oh my god, I'm like scared now.
I'm so scared.
Because like, if we get this, I don't have to try anymore.
Please, please not be...
Please be less than 12.
Please.
Not a lot.
Thank God.
Oh, zero.
Not a lot.
End zero.
Four.
That was actually a crucial wingman drop.
Oh, my God.
This is it.
Oh, I was fracking, too.
Guys, I went full serious mode there.
Chat.
I...
guys i don't know if you guys noticed but i went full
fucking serious mode the moment i was like wait we can win
this like we got wall that's actually really good we can go
to the prowlers oh yeah we have one yeah we had two people
there ready wait i think we all loot the poi we go back to
the prowlers and we just melee them all and let one person
die and it'll be it'll be free we shouldn't even get 30 back
there oh we're at wall yeah that's good we get the yeah yeah
i guys i went full fucking serious we did it guys hopefully
well i mean the team that beat us was crusty and they didn't
get it they didn't get enough no they didn't oh wait wait
there's another person hopping in they might have actually
because it took so long for them to calculate well no bro we
had we had most kills nobody got the 10 kill one either yeah
but others i mean i mean but giggles across the chain yeah
giggles is is she's typing they're calculating right now
Calculators might have it My guy this is like so fucking
scary.
I know I
This is so fucking tense now we're waiting for like the last
couple of people Oh my hands are shaking so hard to out 13th
with one kill so like what could they have done?
I need you guys to know my hands were shaking so fucking
much when it was at 1v1 i would have fucking it wouldn't
matter though because like we wouldn't have got any points
there but then we get to play again on the 28th uh and we
get more money today yeah we can advance to the finals if we
get this did we get do we get money for getting the most
challenges this yeah if most challenges is 1500 and winning
the game is 15 yeah so like imagine if we would have had the
most oh my god that would have been so fat now i'm sick
actual thanos game if we punched them up i know i was so
close we should have just fucking ape them i need i just
need a call for someone to say just fucking punch them that
watson we would not want to regard this the the well the
caustic i dropped on the caustic i died to the caustic and i
thought it was uh i thought it was a 2v1 i didn't know you
said 2v1 because i already knocked i knocked what i thought
it was a bad calm yeah so then i was like oh hey it's your
guy left and then i was like oh hey it's your guy knocked
him when you got knocked and then i was like wait how come
we didn't win the game wasn't over where's the champion and
then and then he me died i was like oh no yeah it was bad i
was hit buying a long bow it's bad mosaic is kind of oop no
wait i heard it actually is nice now like this season i
think maybe uh maybe we just need to be mosaic gamers y'all
i think we did it guys no don't give up my hopes up guys so
don't do this we gotta pray for the legit worst there's
people that have not finished calculating and that's the
scary part four more teams left that need to submit gigos
did not say anything and that freaks me out i know what team
are they on at nine team nine yeah where did they land last
game do we know they got 11 oh okay the team that won okay
wait which team was giggles on uh team nine i don't know p o
'clock they had they had bra i know they have brawler now oh
no team nine got seven she was okay yeah then they're up
there as she posted okay one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve 13 14 15 16 17 there's three
more team guys please three more teams quick just post it oh
no he already posted it minutes ago yeah we won none of us
looked at the leaderboard he posted it no way he put it at
tb decide tbd he puts tpd in leaderboard yeah oh did he edit
it yeah it's official it's official it's official wait crust
is a bastard that could have been a 3k game if crust didn't
clutch up oh my god i know yeah you said he was gonna get a
talking too oh my god wait wait was crusta watson uh he was
a focus on the watson i have no idea we did it guys was the
watson i'm not sure we're taking home a thousand dollars
maybe two thousand if we rate not we don't rate the clip so
what are finals is is finals the same team as you played it
or did they get random it's a whole new it's a whole new
game format i understand yeah it's it's uh random um because
it's like different it's like game modes from all three
tournaments combined together and it's random the other ones
seem too free to play and this one seems like the hardest
one it's like actually still cop apex like the other two uh
the two tournaments it's like mini game like hide and seek
and stuff like that well thursday is actual like thursday is
actual games though because there's duos team death matching
control points okay so that's the actual try those ones
might have those one those one might be easier than these
ones the win of the finals then 20 what day is the finals
the finals there's still two more yeah there's two more
weeks of the finals itself is on the 28th 21st are the
invitation to the finals all right well we did it we
qualified guys now we just get to survive now we don't care
we can so do we we can we can still go for most challenges a
team got game two and three and they counted them oh oh so
we can we can still play for it we'll play the same it
depends which one's easier we either play for the win for
1500 or we play for most challenges for 1500 i think the
challenges is easier yeah the challenges are easier if the
win comes it comes yeah let's just do the same thing let's
just go for most challenges again Perfect.
We have a good game, then Deb.
Perfect, perfect.
Yeah!
We got OCAD out.
My mic is muted.
My push talk doesn't work.
My Discord does break.
We did it!
We got one win!
That was my only goal.
You have to drop us.
My keyboard doesn't work.
Oh shit, wait.
Okay, never mind.
We're at wall?
Okay.
Are you lying to me?
No, no, no.
I don't believe.
I thought pro players have like four, like nine.
I'm good, I'm good.
It's good.
Ooh, just stretch.
Just stretch.
You're good.
No, that's all right.
We can always, we can just run to it.
Just stretch it.
There's nobody there.
We can take the grab can.
Ooh.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll pretend I crash my game.
I might have to take this gravity cannon.
No lie.
Okay, I'm like, no, no, no.
It's fine.
Let's stretch.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, now I...
Okay, now I guess I'll stretch too.
I'm so sorry, guys.
I thought I was going to...
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
We loot the POI and then we loot back to the prowlers when
you do PvE.
I just want you to know I have not fucking stretched in a
long time.
Yay.
You should do that, you know.
Sitting on a computer here all day is bad for you.
No, that's there.
I'll just die young.
No.
But not too young.
Not too young.
I'm rehabilitated.
If we get a good zone, we might just play for God's spot and
play for the one.
Because they're both even at this point.
Oh, we got a good zone.
You should go ahead, Beacon.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got too excited, guys.
I'll go hit the beacon.
I think it's Sentinel.
I'm going to go for the Sentinel knock.
I got a Mozi.
I'm going to steal your loot.
We can loot through the bunker on the way if it's falling
off.
Wait, was the P20?
P20 knock, Mozi, I'm knocked.
Okay, I got a P20.
I got this.
You can be free, he me won.
You want to save 48 for that Sentinel?
We can be free, yeah.
think oh yeah
yeah media i think we just play our game still i'm not gonna
i don't think we'll get god's blood this game i got a fat
way where do i loot we go we can go with the bunker all guys
do everything one one person's supposed to get the bunker i
guess i'll go to the bunker there There's no more loot here.
I'll grab this too.
Hang me a Mozam.
Unless you have one already.
I have a Mozam.
I only I'll peach one.
I have a thermite too.
Should I just come on and do it?
Oh yeah, we can do that.
You should do the one harvesting.
I'm grabbing this evo officer quick.
We do need to be careful.
The zoo station team is going to come down.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
I'm ready.
There you go.
Oh, I actually think we might just go to zone here.
I think it's just going to be pulling down here.
Oh, here's a Mozambique.
I have one.
I have...
Let's go loot.
Let's go loot down to the tunnel and go to zone.
All right.
Oh, wait, the heart.
You can do the heart right now while you're waiting for us.
No, I don't think so.
All right, all right.
I don't have a...
Can we do the thermite one real quick here?
Yeah, we do it.
We can do it inside.
All right.
While you do that, I'll make the heart then.
I'm going to go scout spot.
Just be careful.
This team is going to walk up behind.
Wait, I'll do it.
I'll do it.
You can just res me and Senex can scout.
Yeah, I want to go scout spot.
Yeah, let him scout.
You have a Mozarm, right?
I don't need to pick one up.
Yeah, I have one.
You're good.
Yeah, perfect.
All right, we got the third might.
All right.
Are his shoots?
We're fighting up here.
We might third this.
Okay, I need to heal though.
Give me a sec.
Yeah, you're good.
Okay.
Can Mosey take the disruptors or the hammers?
Just hammers.
Okay, okay.
All right, let me see if I can...
I got the heart!
Heart, heart, heart, heart.
Heart's done.
Beautiful.
Coming over.
I'm gonna come up and scout the booster.
No third on that party?
No, they're not fighting.
They're not fighting.
All right.
Where do we chill?
I'm gonna hit the booster.
Let me see if it's safe.
Okay.
We'll just wait then.
You're good.
You can take it.
it back all of us do uh so you mean i will take it back and
forth only one of us okay one i'll take it back that was one
two three let's just all take it together let's all take
together and come back just pray there's nobody camping this
and then we go for a spot are we doing these prowlers here
or no uh no we're it depends i'm gonna we're gonna rip a
valkal then if god spots open we're gonna go to zone if not
we can do prowlers all right yeah Okay, just land on me and
we're gonna walk up.
How many bats do you guys have?
I have three.
I have two.
What's this?
I'll just drop you one just anyways.
Just hold it for now.
Oh.
All right.
I'll call it.
Number one.
We want this.
We want this or the back building.
Look at both of them.
Do we do the lifeline package yet or no?
No.
I popped the ulti Excel but it wasn't up.
You see anybody over here?
To our right, to our right.
Nobody there.
We're going for you.
this we're going for this there's a harvester yeah just just
keep moving forward because this team might do because i
want to i want to get this cluster of buildings if we can
okay it's either going to end on us or or those buildings so
i'm here just got looted there's no someone to grab this
i'll grab it there's people on the the animal i don't know
what's called the monsters
No, no, no, no.
Push!
Let's set up fences in, man.
We're gonna hold all this.
This bunker and that bunker.
All right.
Let's set up behind us and make sure nobody pushes us.
Okay, I'm setting up.
Want me to set up, how do you want me to set up fences here?
You just spam them.
Some people know we're here.
It doesn't have to be anything crazy.
We're here.
This one fence, so you know.
If we start getting shot in the back and we can't hold this,
we just slide down and play the bunker.
Okay.
Yeah, don't come over here.
You could call in your pack now, but...
the way if you want.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
And Jen as well.
We're in.
Put more fences here.
In the middle of nowhere.
Whoa.
Chill.
Hey, your shots first, man.
You have a gold mag on the sniper.
So wait, let me open up the thing really quick.
Is it a no scope?
Knock with something.
Oh, I'm looking at an old one.
Does anyone have it open?
Or should I tap out and go get it?
Can I have it open?
What is it?
It's a no scope with sentinel and no scope irons.
Yeah, sentinel knock.
It can be charged up though.
And a 360 no scope with sniper.
I'll play for those, I guess.
Oh, you're nuts.
All right.
Let's see.
Can you gen just in this trench right here?
Yeah.
Just like right here?
Yeah, all right.
Yeah, right here.
All right.
We just have to win the fight when this team pushes us.
Be careful.
If you hear a valkalt, they might oob on top of us.
So we just got to be careful.
That's fine.
Don't worry.
I have fences here.
It looks dangerous.
now but i want you guys to know we actually had 13.
whoa wait how do we get 13 because we got seven or more
kills as a team and we got 10 or more kills whoa yeah nice
so we could have been like uh no no no we got 13.
yeah there's a small chance this pulls like the checkpoint
honestly hopefully it doesn't oh man you know what it's not
looking good that's good for overall most challenges a prize
yeah yeah most challenges completed per team how many bats
do you uh do you have i have three here yeah two plus a
phoenix kit that's not i'm gonna get one i'm good i'm doki
should i just whoa i'm getting shot at wait just the person
across if do you have poke to get the purple or no uh for
lifeline pack uh no i have a flatline but i can try okay
that's fine we play sure i don't want any waste suck i'm
gonna use my gen
I don't have any poke at all.
There's a Sentinel here with more ammo.
There's a blue bolt on this if you saw the mozone.
I got one on my...
Thank you.
This guy's very cringe.
This guy, yeah, actually, get a hobby.
You know what?
Who's Valking from over here, the north pad?
Could you put just a couple fences down on like our roof so
people see them?
Yeah, no problem.
I'm gonna take these fences away and then I'll put it on the
roof.
We're playing just for the win this game.
I don't think we've done enough to get the overall
challenges.
Yeah, we don't.
We need two more care packs to consider it.
Three alts.
Two more packs.
I could just revoke alt and count this too.
You could, you could.
I'm just gonna do, I'm literally just gonna revoke alt and
I'll come back down.
I wish we could do the PvEs.
Yeah, I don't think we can at this point.
I don't think we can, yeah.
We probably could have done that.
We definitely could have done the other one.
I honestly assume someone would take zone, to be honest.
Arc star, Arc star on that car.
Waco, get ready for them to land on our roof.
They just popped the Waco from the checkpoint.
Just look up.
We have a team rotating towards us.
I'm coming over.
I'm going to look above us.
We're good.
They're not going to summon us yet.
Somebody, hold on.
I'm here.
They won't.
I think this is, they might just hold this.
They might just hold that bunker there.
They won't.
My senses are scary.
Yeah.
I think they're just in there.
Turtling.
Park going right here.
Okay.
I'm looking.
I cannot, I don't have any scopes or range for anything.
I might be able to get you one here.
Do you need a one or two?
I have it on a probably.
Uh, yeah, that'll be great.
I'll need that for my P20 later too.
All right.
Quay!
Oh, what the fuck?
Chill.
I'm gonna charge up my armor for free.
Purple shotgun bolt.
I got it.
I'm good.
Oh, knocked Watson right here.
Nice knock.
Flocko, Flocko, Flocko.
Flocko, Flocko.
Flocko, they...
I'm gonna walk up a little bit.
I'm gonna be able to, actually, no, no, no, no, it's our
skills.
Yeah.
I might die here.
Just gotta do this.
Bad idea.
Too many people.
I'm gonna pop a Phoenix.
My Watson also have charge, yeah.
Yeah, I'm gonna hop on it.
Oh, he was so close too.
Did you, uh, drum?
Yeah, I think they're going to push.
Thank you.
Oh, we're still in zone.
We're still in.
It's probably going to be this cluster of buildings, but if
we clear our edge, we should have a free walk in.
So we just have to win this fight on the scene that pushes
us on our edge.
I'm worried there's going to be a team coming from behind.
We should be, it should be pretty hard for them to push us.
This team should help us.
So we LOS left.
All right.
And we just play like the backside right here.
Wait, they're trying to rotate.
They're swinging.
They're swinging far right.
Okay.
What do you think?
I think I just saw something.
Whoa, chill.
chill oh please don't get a curber they got the care package
right there are you serious they get a curber jesus christ
no all right um we we just can't peek them just don't pick
them at all he's gonna they're gonna like launch out one of
us i'm gonna grab this six x scope and snake a little if we
end up having to fight just fight through the right over
here if you have to okay all right and then worst case
scenario we slide back and we play in bunker with a gen
behind this team rotating oh there's a teammate here team to
north 22.
that's good are you they're rotating purple or no for
lifeline probably not i'm not there's a guy his teammates
over there i don't want to like just burn my ammo i have
167.
i don't know you're good you're good you just hold that's a
no wait are you leaving wait that means that's another team
over here that's rotating yep oh i can't get it Careful,
charge Sentinel behind you.
All right, it's fine.
I have a...
This is bad.
I'm not...
Are they fighting out there?
Seven of me, yep.
Cracked one.
Over here, there's a catalyst here.
If they fight, I'm going to charge my Sentinel and run up
and try to knock one.
Oh, Jesus.
Is anybody looking at our backs?
I'm worried that...
Yeah, that's...
Yeah.
You're looking back.
I'm going to look at our side then.
Oh, we got a creeper.
We got a creeper on us.
i can grab i can grab that oh my god whoa i'm gonna i'm
gonna drop my sentinel okay i can refresh do you want me to
refresh it or no oh yeah yeah can you get ready to look over
me i might die going for the scrap package yeah yeah i'm
gonna watch back so i'm gonna shoot shoot the building team
the same borrow your scope then right do i go with the car
okay bro i'm looking over here to my right they're fighting
on our ass oh fuck okay i feel like the heal now i can't
kind of not on our ass but like behind us sorry but they are
in this choke behind um dropping we have like god spot we
have we've got spot we just need to we need to just on this
zone we need to just kill the scene behind us on your ping
did you grab your uh wait can i take your sentinel stuff
i've preparedness nightmare i have remember i'm throwing my
third care pack i'm throwing my third care back yeah play
the play the pack los and then we just need to kill this
team on the run-in all right i'm i'm swapping back to my p20
then yeah because in case they run up i'm gonna syringe 140
on the one side oh i broke the john look at this if you have
your signal you might be able to knock one i don't have my
signal i swap i can't cook i need a finished that's okay
that's okay yeah we we literally just have to look at the i
thought they were gonna push up closer so i got my p20.
okay i'm gonna bring this in a little closer to me then be
careful this this left team might walk up on us while we're
doing this so we just have to play we just have to play more
towards the right and then we just have to hard find them
I'm like just rotating my sentinel back and forth.
Okay.
I'm gonna play roof and try to curb everyone.
It's lifeline caustic.
Where is the team to the left?
I think they're in the lower.
I hear them sliding here.
Yeah, they're below us.
Below us, right here.
Yeah, close, close.
I'm gonna go for a curb shot.
I see them.
Right here.
We can't fight them until we know there's nobody on our
right.
They're gonna try to fight us though.
They are, yeah.
They have hound caustic.
They're nading, nading, nading.
That might be them.
I'm looking.
We're playing to kill them.
We have to play to kill them.
I stunned two.
All right.
Cosmic at 190, 190.
Get ready to walk up.
I'm on the next time.
I'm walking, walking, walking, walking.
I'm at P20.
You're backing up.
I'm labeling on.
After that.
I stunned one on the right.
You can play slow.
You can play a little slow, still.
I'm going to play for a curve shot.
Careful.
Careful, Hemi.
You're really...
Oh, I'm blocked.
I'm covering.
I'm covering for you.
Thank you, Vicky.
All right, I can't even have a shot from this guy.
Hopping a bat.
fencing this I'm going to zone yeah we need to kill them for
a reset I'm going to play I have one more nade I have one
more nade that I can use okay try to sky nade them I'm going
to swing left here and try to cover one I'm waiting for a
scan I'm waiting for a scan they're going to push they're
going to push okay I'm melting I'm melting oh hard walking
up hard walking up I'm winning space live by 140 no that's a
good one I'm climbing on me climbing climbing climbing Up on
me, on me, on me.
Just out, just out right here.
Oh, it's bad.
Yeah.
Good try.
That wingman is so...
Yeah, he had the wingman.
Oh.
That wingman helped.
It's okay, we thirsted their second.
We thirsted.
GG's, we made finals.
It's okay, we made finals.
That's all that matters.
What's our count for this line?
I don't even think it mattered.
That's not enough, yeah.
I don't think we're going to do that here.
We accounted for the overall.
You want to count?
Yeah, we should count it for the overall.
Yeah, yeah.
The overall.
That's fine.
We got the- Actually sucks.
I had shot this guy, but he had a purple helmet, so he
didn't die.
We did the knock with the thermal.
We didn't do any PVs, though.
No, we did not.
We were just playing through the- We did the gravity cannon.
We did the heart.
One, two, three, four.
Yeah, the heart.
That's it.
That's actually it.
Oh, and my old four times.
No survival.
No survival items.
Yeah, I counted that.
Yeah.
kind of that way it was uh before it was knock with the
thermite don't use survival gravity cannon watson heart and
use the old three times that's four and that is well that's
five that's five five you know five's great good effort wait
did you get a p did you get the p20 knock or no i use the i
got it with the prowler yeah i didn't get it i had it with
the prowler so yay we made it Yeah, good job.
All right, y'all.
Is this it, right?
It's the last game.
Yeah, that was last game.
Oh my god, this has been almost like four hours.
This was long.
For six fans, it was long.
To be fair.
I mean, like, imagine if we could have walked up on this
nonsense, like this would have been free.
I don't know.
They're dying right now.
I know, but we would have been able to, like, walk up.
Or would I have wingman Krabry?
They're actually deleted.
We would have had triple Krabry.
That's true.
Oh, wait, they get free red!
no someone push him oh that creeper yes come on he's
literally one hit it's so close wait why am i watching
looking oh my god he's gonna win it oh my god he's gonna win
oh that's insane that was crazy that was crazy that was
insane game from them wait can we see the standings there's
no standings it's like a game each each game is its own
thing yeah there's there isn't any overall standings yeah
there's gonna be the only overall thing will be uh two most
skills overall yeah i don't think that's i had any of them
that's on the controller please it's a legit impossible i
mean this is rigged each team should have one controller
player that was fun that was fun ggs we made it to the
that's all it matters i know i'm so proud of us oh my god we
almost got like champion and finals that would have been
sick though that would have been so sick so we're not
allowed to play the other ones right no i think we are i
think we get invited i don't know why not yeah i think they
might not just invite because we already made finals uh
that's true they want to give everyone a chance at finals i
guess so yeah i'm gonna play on an altar or something but
it's not fair the sounds so fun.
There's the one of the, what's it, the Watson punch up.
And then the trio no weapons.
That sounds so fucking fun.
I agree.
Yeah.
Yeah, we actually got the hard one.
You actually have to like try it.
I thought the first one was the easiest.
That's why I signed up for it.
We're going to be watching the next week and they're just
going to be playing hide and seek, like hiding in bushes and
stuff.
I'm so sad.
I was like, oh man, this first one with the mini games that
one has to be the hide and seek one i was wrong i was so
wrong we did great though i'm proud of us great yeah ggs
guys ggs everybody it was great meeting all of you guys yeah
ggs bye bye guys bye peace oh my god we did it guys we got
to the find us easy thousand dollars when are the finals um
the finals are March 28th uh so just look forward to that
I'm just I don't know if I can actually participate in the
other ones I wish I could participate in the other ones the
other ones are so fun like I really wanted to do the the
March 21st with the the three strikes no weapons and Watson
punch out the Watson punch out is apparently like um the
players have to kill Watson character on the other team via
punching.
Like, that sounds so fucking fun.
I, I, you know, I'm just gonna be, I'm gonna ask him.
Tempo.
Can I still do the other, damn it!
Even though I got into the finals.
I'm gonna ask him.
Because the other ones sound so fun.
Let me in!
Let's...
I got...
Let her in!
Alright.
Anyway, they still have to apparently check the...
Check, like, to make sure, like...
Guys, do we have any cool clips, guys?
Do we have any more cool clips?
Because they're going to be voting for clips, I think.
Then put the letter in.
Guys, are there any more cool clips?
We can get, like, 3,000.
Wait, what was it, 2,000?
Sorry, no.
We can 2,000.
Wait, no, we can technically get 3,000 if we want two of the
clips.
If both of our clips are really, really good.
Okay, let's see.
All right, no, this is...
No, not these clips.
Okay.
Why did you clip me spiking a heart?
Okay, no, none of these Clippers as good.
No.
Okay, we submitted three clips, guys.
When are they gonna vote for the clips?
When are they?
We just need to wait for them to start voting.
We just need to have the vote, and then we're good to go.
vote let me in let me in okay so apparently um what's left
is the clip i don't know if i should wait until uh until the
clip the clip vote or if i should um if i should um just
call it i don't know how the clip stuff is gonna work like
are they doing the vote now or the introvert clip is called
okay all right i'll post that no that's bad because it's
like you just see my pain i'm trying to fucking talk to
people
okay well let me what the fuck that's just me spilling my
bubble tea that's fucked up
what the fuck do you mean it's relatable okay fine i'll post
this uh Everybody else's clips, guys, I'll just have you
know, everybody else's clips are, like, gameplay.
Everyone else's clips are, like, gameplay clips.
And then I'm just the one being, like, look at all this shit
I fucked up on.
Look at all this shit.
It sets you apart.
Like, what is this bullshit, guys?
guys this is not fair all my clips are like everybody else
it's like look 1v4 wingman clutch triple sentinel knock 1a
285 damage and then you guys goodbye you're dead team
discussing the strats dokey
Sand Knox unalives himself.
Guys, what the fuck is this?
It didn't like this one.
Epic win.
Playmaker.
Final two teams.
What do you mean?
What is this bullshit?
Give me something that makes me look good.
You got the flavor clear lips.
You're like, you already caught me creator for a reason this
is not fair why i like oh my god oh my god this one has
subtitles wait oh my god this is so bullshit this is
actually so bullshit guys this is so bullshit why why don't
i get the cool clips
we don't need to look good we are
This is bullshit!
I should have good clips!
I did so...
I was so fucking cool in some of them.
Come on, we're helping you stand out.
That is true.
But the people that are voting for this are all fucking Apex
Watchers.
They don't give a fuck about content.
They don't...
What the fuck do you mean?
These are Apex Watchers.
They don't care about what's funny.
They care about what's cool.
Wait, no, wait, no, there is big brain.
Guys, no, I got it.
This is so big brain.
Because all the Apex Watchers are going to be split vote.
They're all going to be split vote because all these clips
are all, like, so cool.
Wait, no, you guys are actually... You guys are actually
really smart.
You guys are actually so smart.
You're splitting all the votes.
We're splitting all the votes of, like, all the...
on me fucking all the cool clips so then people who just
wanted to laugh they'll vote for me because they'll laugh at
me not with me and then so god I don't know if that's the
thing is I don't know if there's enough voters that will
vote for that I don't know
the only issue is that I don't know we have enough voters
that will vote for that though so What if there's not
enough?
We just need a vote.
Yeah, that's totally the plan.
Are they voting for the clips now?
What are they?
Okay, let's see.
All right.
Do we have any more?
Okay, I'll send in one more funny clip.
You'll get the undecided voters.
That's where we're aiming at right now.
We are the undecided voters.
okay i would send one more clip into the category there's so
many clips i'm the only one that sent more than one like i'm
actually like just spamming them like i'm just i'm just
spamming them right now we are in the exception here all
right okay what else what what can we uh what can we send
okay all right let's see i'm trying i'm gonna see i'm trying
to see i need to know what can we vote okay the voting is
happening in like the community's like girls discord right
now uh so like uh so like we can't vote for it because we're
not in her discord uh send the voting it's happening
We're not gonna raid her discord just to vote.
Wait, what is this?
Wait, drop the post to the clip.
Is it a cool clip or is it a ha ha funny clip?
Oh!
Shit!
Guys, no!
I'm good!
How are we going to...
Guys!
How are we gonna beat this?
He took the ha ha ha vote!
How do we beat that?
Good!
It's over.
It's so over.
I linked it.
I fucking linked it.
This, that one.
Yeah, that one was pretty funny.
No!
I did.
I sent the link.
It's over.
It's so over.
We're not gonna win.
We're not gonna win the ha-ha clip now.
We're not gonna win the ha-ha clip.
It's over.
Even you guys know it's over.
You guys know... Yeah, that was...
That's over!
Going down knowing that you tried.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Alright.
Okay, alright.
I will...
I will send one last clip, guys.
I will send one last clip.
I'll send one last clip.
Is there anything that we have?
That's good.
Do we have anything?
We tried.
It's over.
Okay, never mind.
We all gave up.
All right.
I'm not gonna wait until...
I'm not gonna see who got the clips that it's over.
Introvert clip is still fun.
Fine.
I'll do the introvert.
Wait, are you the one that fucking made that clip?
Is that why you keep chilling in?
No, you're not.
Okay, I'll...
Fine.
Now I'll send the introvert clip over.
All right, I'm going to call it here.
That was fun, though.
Okay, for those who don't know, change a schedule.
I'll post this on Twitter.
And I'll post this on Twitter later.
But there has been a change of schedule.
Oh, shit.
Okay, so this is the new schedule now.
We changed it to fit people's, other people's schedule.
So Resident Evil 4 and Hufobia are both swapped now.
So over here, tomorrow, it's Hufobia.
And then for those who are like, what the fuck is Hufobia?
It's basically like, you play as either a hunter or deers.
And then the hunter has to, like, try to kill the deers.
And it's not just, like, three deers.
There's, like, lots of deers.
And then the deers have to pretend to be deers.
and like beat the shit out of the hunter so so like that's
basically it so it's like deers versus hunters um inside you
are two deers yeah i've been wanting to play that game for a
while but i like there was like no multiplayer but then they
recently added multiplayer like they recently i mean there
was multiplayer but there's no private servers but they
recently added private servers now so like i'm looking
forward to it uh so So that's who phobia.
And then obviously, Resident Evil 4, I saw people asking if
it was the original or the remake.
I will be playing the remake because I don't want to
restart.
I don't want to go back from the beginning.
I don't want to replay the original.
So we're going to be playing the remake.
So at least we can finish it this time.
anyway anyway that is the current schedule hey guys i hope
you guys had a great time um i'm so happy we made it to the
finals i honestly did not expect us to make it to the finals
and um it's it's hard being the extroverted introvert
because i tried my best to be social amongst apex streamers
because that is very difficult to do when you are the most
uh social person there as the introvert so
so i tried my best anyway uh thank you everybody for coming
as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and
move around to get that blood flowing if you and you said
for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys
next time everybody bye guys